make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah let's
begin what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are getting into James tenon's
Batman run and we're I mean at the end
of the video we're going to talk about
punchline a lot of you guys have been
asking about her we don't really have
any information on her right but a lot
of you guys have been asking so I
figured I would title this you know
punchline the the Joker's new girlfriend
uh but she's had some scant appearances
and from what I understand she's not
really going to be a major player in in
Batman comics until we get to the Joker
War but you guys have been asking about
her you've been asking me to dump some
information on her so at the end of the
video I'll give you guys what we have in
any
event here's the thing about James
tenon's run right and this is one of the
things to kind of be weary of when it
when it comes to to stories right James
Tiny's Batman run is amazing so far but
so is Tom King's and the the issue is
that by the time you got to the end of
Tom King's run it really kind of just
seemed to be an exercise and
self-indulgence with a great big huge
story that really just didn't go
anywhere it's possible tenon's run could
go in that direction we don't really
know yet but the cool thing about this
is that tenyon is writing Batman the way
he's been writing Detective Comics which
is awesome because his run on Detective
Comics is amazing like it's it's
ridiculously good I feel like it's one
of the unsung heroes of like DC right
now right like it's a super good story
but what this does is it initially picks
up uh seemingly with a kind of coming
together of various villains right but
the first person we really pick up here
with is a character by the name of
Cheshire now Cheshire is a longstanding
enemy of the team the the funny thing
about Chesire is she's unique and you
know really in comparison to a lot of
the different like mercenaries and
villains who are out there right because
when you look at the people who are here
you have like Mr teeth which we'll we'll
talk about him here in a little bit
you've got Malcolm Merlin kind of the
antithesis of Green Arrow and the the
Green Arrow comics you've got you know
you got gunsmith who's actually a pretty
cool character in and of himself uh and
then of course you have a fifth person
here we'll find out who they are here in
a second but Cheshire among all the
various Contract Killers out there is
unique because of the fact that
basically her hair her fingernails
things like that are all tainted with
different poisons right so like at any
point in time she could scratch you and
you could die from like the Venom of an
Asp snake or in this instance where she
killed the the doorman the Venom of what
was basically a box jellyfish like the
these things are cool right it's it's
one of the things that makes her really
intriguing and really interesting but it
makes her difficult to capture right
because she's like a tree frog right
like like an Amazonian tree frog the the
entirety of her body is basically a
giant poison and so if you were to to
touch her you were to grab her hair or
you were to be SC by her nails or bit by
her or something like that or even
possibly touch her skin you could die
and so it's it's interesting like she's
really intriguing in that way but what
this also does is it kind of switches
over to Catwoman now here's one of the
cool things here right with Selena Kyle
this is one of the things that I love
about what tenon's doing that that Tom
King did differently whenever Tom King
had like Batman and Catwoman talking it
just didn't sound natural right it was
it was like watching an alen sorin show
right so like The Newsroom or like The
West Wing where people have
conversations but no one really talks
like that in real life and it kind of
removed you from the comic right like
nobody talks that way like when they
would communicate and things like that
Tenon does a really really good job of
having discussions between characters
and it really just kind of feels organic
the way that that Selena Kyle and
Batwoman talk it's not the most
important thing out there but it is kind
of a cool thing the other part of this
that you really end up learning here is
that Bruce Wayne is kind of going or at
least Batman's going headlong into the
notion of like developing Gotham City
right he's going into the notion of like
developing Gotham and just making it a
better place as opposed to I'm running
around as Batman and I'm beating up
criminals in the middle of the night
like I'm some kind of a schizophrenic
and like and that's my that's my stick
that's my thing right like he's actually
working to improve Gotham more so than
he ever did before and in fact Tenon
will kind of address this unlike years
past but the cool thing is that that
what he ends up doing is is really kind
of having this conversation with Lucius
Fox right where Batman is in the midst
of developing this not not really a
Batmobile but not really a Batwing kind
of a blend between the two to a degree
which is somewhat of of an interesting
idea but the big takeaway from this is
he basically says that about 5 days
prior on the dark web that the the back
computer picked up a message that was
sent out and then deleted 3 minutes
later and what this basically did was
kind of sent out a message to five of
the most capable uh assassins out there
in the world and basically said meet in
Gotham City on this day and we're going
to complete a mission and that basically
Deathstroke is the one who's leading
them and this is an interesting thing
here because Batman really sort of
analyzes all the villains who were there
and it's just kind of like okay each one
of these guys are interesting you know
Mr teeth and and gunsmith and Cheshire
and so on but the only person that I'm
really worried about here is Deathstroke
because for Deathstroke it's about the
money but also about the principal if
somebody's going to hire him for a job
it has to be worth doing right because
Deathstroke has enough money so it's one
of these things where he doesn't really
need the cash it's is it worth my while
to even take this job in the first place
which he can kind of Command right he's
like the premier assassin in DC Comics
so like if you really want somebody to
die death stroke's the guy you get a
hold of so it's kind of interesting and
so because this Batman's essentially
plann for for a lot of these villains to
take them down but also realizes that
Deathstroke's mind operating as fast as
it does and in fact this kind of
established here n times faster than the
average man means a Batman has to act
and then respond in really an
exceedingly short amount of time
otherwise Deathstroke will mentally get
the upper hand and this is an important
thing because what it shows here is that
while Bruce Wayne doesn't really
consider Deathstroke to be an equal he
does consider Deathstroke to be somebody
worth worrying about and death stroke is
in a lot of ways an equal to to Batman
not you know strictly in terms of
fighting but in terms of his Ingenuity
how his mind works his ability to
comprehend and understand situations to
get in and out of different scenarios as
fast as possible I mean for God's sake
the guy with facing off against Superman
and just threws like glowing green rocks
at him and tricks Superman into thinking
it was Kryptonite right so like small
little things like that are what really
make Deathstroke unique and intriguing
here and so of course Batman executes
this plan and basically you know throws
out what are called the bat Shadow
casters and what these are designed to
do is basically kind of emit a shadow
that more or less follows these various
villains around and then tricks them
into believing they're leading Batman
into a trap right where they can somehow
take him out when in reality he's not
there now of course going toe-to-toe
against Deathstroke is a cool thing to
see with Deathstroke being there him and
Batman facing off against each other
it's largely been established multiple
times over DC Comics that sometimes the
battle can actually go either way that
sometimes Deathstroke can win because of
his super soldier enhancements sometimes
Batman can win because Batman's just the
best fighter in in DC Comics but
regardless you know basically what
Deathstroke says here is like you
fighting me this is the distraction this
is this is part of the big plan right
like this is all going the way it's
supposed to and Batman's response is I
know exactly what's going on like I know
what it is that you're trying to do and
that's when we basically pick up with
Catwoman who followed a guy down into uh
this kind of sub basement with all this
information with the plans of Bruce
Wayne in fixing Gotham City and and kind
of what it is that he wants to do with
the city as a whole are intending to be
replaced with a new set of designs by a
person called the designer and the cool
thing about this is that when when you
know this happens when this goes down
and Catwoman confronts this guy uh
ultimately he's just kind of like you
have to stop this guy like I don't care
what you have to do but you have to stop
this guy's plans from coming to fruition
after which this guy immediately begins
to die kind of breaking down and and so
on but it disembodied voice singly
starts to kind of come out out of this
guy's body and basically saying like
Catwoman I see you I know you're here
you know you have to understand this
plan that that was concocted some time
ago that you were a part of it's now
coming to fruition right the designer is
coming for Gotham City the Catwoman
immediately picks up on what's going on
and so what this does is it hits back to
this idea that somewhere along the line
in part of the of the history of of
Gotham City which we haven't really
known about before that Catwoman
seemingly made a deal or made some kind
of a bargain with this designer guy but
we don't really know how far this goes
right just kind of hitting at this idea
that there's some pretty clandestine
stuff going on but the cool thing about
this is that this Rabbit Hole goes down
pretty far and we'll find out how far it
goes but what this does is it jumps to
Batman who basically jumps on his
communicator and says Alfred send a
priority signal to the Gotham City
police department and this is this is
cool because my initial thought was oh
my God Gotham's back but it's
interesting to see tenan kind of picking
up on what it is a Tom King did and
continuing that continuity because
Alfred's dead and that's where Lucius
chimes in and says Alfred is isn't here
anymore man like Alfred's Alfred's gone
Batman and Batman slipped right he knew
that that Alfred was gone but it was
just one of these things where he's so
used to doing it it's crushing for him
to have to have to admit that Alfred's
not here and he actually just kind of
you know seems to cry I mean some of it
seems like rain but I would say Batman
kind of seems to cry in response to this
and so as a result he basically tells
Lucius grab that that ship thing you
know we'll grab the villains and we'll
we'll take them off and that'll
basically be the end of that and so what
you basically end up doing is you end up
jumping to Riddler who's having a
conversation with the penguin of course
the penguin killing various people who
were there and this is when things get
cool because what the Riddler says is
I've been watching everything that's
been going on with gosam City I've been
watching all these things take place so
on and so forth and like the the the
designer is coming to town right the
designer is here in Gotham City the
response of penguin is yeah I know and
I've taken out anybody who knows what it
is that I've been doing right who knows
about my plans or anything like that
literally all the villains are basically
cleaning house what whoever this
designer is whoever this this guy is
here whatever whatever it is he's
capable of and and whatever he's about
is scaring the hell out of out of the
villains right it's scaring them enough
to where penguin is killing off his
henchman so there's no one there to drop
any information and the Riddler's scared
out of his wits right the Riddler is
just like dude this guy is no joke and
so it's it's kind of crazy because you
know we've seen things with like Bane
taking over Gotham City so on and so
forth the difference between this this
you know the way this is going down and
what Tom King did is that in this story
you feel the stakes you're like okay so
like something's getting ready to pop
off in
Gotham something really bad is getting
ready to happen but that's the thing is
is the Riddler's response is like the
designer is coming to collect the
designer is coming for all of us coming
for all of us as the villains and
penguin's respons is he can try and so
this is when things get interesting
because from there you pick up with the
various villains of course who have
essentially been apprehended by Batman
and what you learn is you have this
place called the black block and the
Black Block is basically this this
prison that's designed to hold people
that that are Escape Escape dangers now
the reason why this is awesome and this
is an amazing invention by by James
tenyon because I'm pretty pretty sure
he's the one who made it when you look
at the Batman Mythos and you look at
like Arkham Asylum Arkham is for the
most part a revolving door right like
too faace or penguin or Joker or or any
number of those guys Riddler Madhatter
or whoever you know the Mr Freeze
they're busted by Batman and then it's
only a matter of time before they escape
from Arkham in order to avoid this what
Batman had done working alongside Lucius
Fox and and really even the Gotham City
Police Department was create the Black
Block as a place where escaping
criminals right so like Bane and Joker
people like that who present a clear and
present danger to to Gotham City itself
could be held and detained that you
basically got 10 ft of cement which is
lined with concrete the idea is that
like no one can get out of here right
like once you're in you're in and
there's only two ways in and out of this
whole Black Block the first one is
basically a DNA encoded set of keys that
are only used by Gotham City police
department and the second one is an
interest that only Batman knows about
and so when Batman gets in there and
starts talking to to Deathstroke
Deathstroke is immediately like hey man
like you know I'm not going to tell you
who it was that hired me so don't waste
your time the other people don't know so
they can't tell tell you but here's the
thing one I'm going to break out of here
right I'm not going to be in here
forever this is a cool little game
you're playing and I like that you
believe you can hold me it's cute but
understand I'm Deathstroke right like I
will get out of this place and then two
this is a game that you're playing it's
it's interesting to watch you play this
game because you're going to lose and
it's and it's going to be fun to watch
you fail but this is a game that you
will not win so wish me luck when I get
out of here and that's when Batman
basically tells Bullock who's basically
operating as a commissioner presumably
because of the events of of the Batman
who laughs and the fact that
Commissioner Gordon is basically there
with with the Batman who laughs as part
of his you know evil group or whatever
his evil justice league who cares
nobody's reading that anymore the thing
is like when he basically has the cell
of Cheshire opened up Batman rubs her
face and then realizes that it's Clay
that it's a body double right like it's
not actually Cheshire herself and so
immediately goes on the defensive with
Lucius say track you know find Cheshire
track her down they successfully do they
end up locating her and one of the most
crazy things to come out of this and
this this batwing you know ship thing
that Bruce Wayne has he shoots himself
out of the rail
gun he literally shoots himself out of
the rail gun in order to track her down
as fast as possible because of the fact
that the buildings she's traveling
between are too narrow for him to just
like swoop down and and pick her up with
like some kind of a chain and then do
like he did in Detective Comics Number
27 where he just hangs her and it's just
like she's better off this way but
nonetheless you know jumping out of here
or at least when when a Cheshire makes
makes her move to try to take out Bruce
Wayne and then immediately goes to
basically dig her nails into his uh into
his skin that the intention is that he's
going to end up dying from whatever
poison he's exposed to now of course
this leads to uh basically Cheshire
being hit by a truck while Batman slides
underneath it and while it's not enough
to kill her it is enough to incapacitate
her and then of course Batman reveals
that he basically had a kind of uh
membrane in his suit that essentially
absorb the poison so you know Batman's
plot armor strikes again but then at
that moment suddenly Deathstroke and all
of his guys escape from the facility and
that's when we basically end up finding
out here that what was going on is that
penguin basically made his move right
penguin had jumped in here and penguin
was the one who freed all of these guys
he's the one that got them all out of
there which is kind of a cool thing to
see and so then what you do is you
basically jump to to the Riddler having
a conversation with Catwoman the
Catwoman's basically made her way to a
cemetery after that you know
conversation with with the one guy who
she believed to have been dead ends up
having a conversation with her and
basically saying hey I haven't used this
line for quite some time but you have to
understand we all made a deal with the
designer we made a deal with him and
he's coming to collect so you me anybody
who was involved with that we're all
either going to die or we're going to
have to play ball the indication is that
the designer is going to kill them all
right that's the indication he's going
to kill all the villains of Batman
that's why this is so cool right because
the stakes feel so intense right it's
just like dude all the villains of
Batman are going to die and it sucks
especially for Catwoman because she's a
good guy now and it's one of the things
that's really kind of communicated here
when it comes to uh to Riddler is he
says the whole reason why we got
together with the designer was to commit
quote unquote The Perfect Crime but
basically you know houses being cleaned
by all of us me as a riddler I never
really had henchman so I don't really
have to worry about that I'm basically
going to like I'm getting out of here
like I'm jumping ship the penguin
cleaned house on his end we have to
assume that if there are any other
villains that are involved they've done
the exact same thing as well but the
belief of Catwoman is that the Joker
somehow involved here and so of course
traveling to the cemetery this is done
for the intention of finding the casket
of the Joker which he does he's
basically laying down inside this casket
now for those of you guys who are unsure
or who who are kind of looking at this
like where did the Joker die this this
basically appeared to have happened back
in Batman issue number 49 by uh Tom King
as part of leadup to the wedding that
never happened between Batman and
Catwoman and there was kind of like this
Killing Joke moment right where where uh
Catwoman and and Joker got into a fight
and then she slashed his throat with her
claws and then they had this great big
huge long you know conversation
basically which Tom King did with
unnecessarily with a lot of situations
but basically at the end of it Joker
seemingly died right he just kind of
seemed to have been dead ever since now
continuity wise I don't know how that
fits into Doomsday Clock I don't think
DC knows I don't think they really care
enough to to figure it all out but the
the long and short of it is that at the
moment right now all indications are
that the Joker's dead right so the
question becomes if the Joker's dead
then how is his disembodied voice
communicating with anybody who's out
there right like or seemingly
communicating with her at least this
Catwoman believed and so the other part
of this is of course Batman uh
essentially apprehending Cheshire is
then contacted by Lucius Fox who gives
him one of the coolest inventions ever
what he basically says is that inside of
your of your utility belt is a device
called The Echo and what the echo does
is it basically allows you to attach it
to any vehicle that's out there which in
turn will have back into the Wayne
Enterprises components within the car
and then basically allow the car's
appearance to change it creates a kind
of hologram but it'll make any car look
like a Batmobile and then it'll allow it
to drive as fast as the Batmobile which
is cool because basically what this
means is a Batman's got a Batmobile in
his pocket right like at any point in
time he can just slap this thing onto a
car and then drive off now Batman's
response is like you want me to jack a
car and then turn it into a Batmobile
and then drive and Lucius is like well
it's my car so you're fine but
nonetheless the funny thing is that you
you know kind of switching back to
Catwoman in the midst of this whole
thing where she kind of comes to
frustration with the fact that one the
Riddler basically says I'm cutting this
line now I'm leaving there'll be no more
communication for between you and me
good luck with the designer hopefully
you get out in time but understand that
you're probably going to have to break
this news to Batman something that you
know this kind of ultimate betrayal more
or less that you committed against him
without him really knowing she's also
met with the arrival of these these two
kind of henchmen of sorts you know who
basically show up and then essentially
you know almost kind of knock her out or
knock her unconscious and then start
burying her there along with the joker
you know and so of course picking up
with the penguin you know the penguin
basically there with Deathstroke and all
those guys is kind of like look like
here's the deal I'm I'm skipping town
right like I'm getting out of here I
don't want to have anything to do with
the designer I know the designer was the
one that hired you guys I will pay you
double your rate if you guys leave
Gotham and then you guys sign a
non-compete CL Clause basically you
won't return to goth within a calendar
year and the response to Deathstroke is
you couldn't afford my price right so
you can't even afford double my price
and then in turn intends to go and kill
the penguin only for Batman to basically
show up and then of course you know know
he's kind of told hey man just so you
know like d you know attaching the echo
to any car does not give you the kind of
armor that the Batmobile has so just
keep that in mind
man it's just a hologram right so if
they shoot you it's you're probably
going to die if you get shot in like the
jaw or something like that somewhere
where your armor doesn't protect you but
for the most part the various henchmen
who are here are overtaken like that
right I mean they're they're for the
most part taken out quick fast and in a
hurry by Batman at which point the you
know Death Stroke responds stop like if
you keep fighting I'm going to kill the
Penguin and so it's cool because Malcolm
Merlin grabs tesser the villains make
their escape and Deathstroke slices the
throat of the Penguin and it's dude like
when this happened I was like holy cow
dude like dude is a penguin going to
die the classic villains of Batman are
basically being killed off you know so
of course this leads to Deathstroke
making the smart move it's the smartest
move for him to make right knowing
Batman as he knows him he knows that
Batman will not let the penguin die
right Batman despite all the glitz and
Glamour and all the stuff that he does
is a champion of life right so he's not
going to let the penguin die and so
Deathstroke knows this and he
essentially say says you have one of two
choices either you can come after us and
you can let the penguin die or you can
save penguin but we know you're not
going to let him die we know how this
game's going to play out we'll see you
when we see you we're going to go after
our targets and basically they end up
leaving while Batman goes to save
penguin himself and so with that going
down the penguin in turn spills the
beans and basically says years ago right
you never knew about this nobody ever
told you but years ago myself Joker
Catwoman like Riddler the underworld
essentially United to commit the perfect
crime and the perfect crime was to take
out Bruce Wayne Right to Ally ourselves
with the designer and the designer's
goal was to take out Bruce Wayne that
these guys here right these you know
Deathstroke and all those guys they're
there to take out false targets the way
this looks like it was supposed to go
down is that Batman was not supposed to
know what was actually going on that
instead you'd have these criminals who
showed up here they would take out false
targets bat would Chase around try to
figure out what's going on and the
designer instead would basically take
out the plans of Bruce Wayne to destroy
what it is that he wanted to do with
Gotham City itself the other indication
here is that if the designer is looking
to take out Bruce Wayne that would seem
arbitrary right like I mean he's just a
really rich guy as far as the world's
concerned all all anybody you know aside
from the Justice League and the
individuals who know that Bruce Wayne is
Batman Bruce Wayne is just a really rich
guy who's trying to make Gotham better
seemingly the indication here is the
designer knows that Bruce Wayne is
Batman like that that kind of seems to
be what the case is now there you know
it's it's cool to see that because then
you switch over of course to Catwoman
and Catwoman basically kind of digs
herself out you know she's like I'm not
going to die here like I'm not going to
die buried alive in a grave with the
Joker's Court like that's ridiculous you
know she kind of ends up jumping out and
then of course is saved by none other
than Harley Quinn which is kind of crazy
because it's like why in the heck is
Harley Quinn even here which is kind of
nuts now of course from there the
penguin is basically dropped off at like
a Gotham City hospital by Batman
literally Batman grabbed the penguin
drove to this location out of the
vehicle left him on the steps of the
hospital and was like I got stuff to do
and then
left which is kind of screwed up but
Batman ends up going after these false
targets right now this is important
because what this shows is Batman is
trying to do it all right now the
reality is Batman wouldn't let the false
targets die right that was the whole
message of the penguin you know gunsmith
and Mr teeth and and Cheshire and uh and
Deathstroke you know so on you know
they're going to go after the false
targets and they're going to kill them
right so innocent people are basically
going to die if Batman chose not to go
after these guys and that's kind of the
danger of all this right like the
designer really seems to be
orchestrating things in such a way to
where Batman's being pushed to his
limits and in a lot of ways he is
because this comes hot off the heels of
everything that just happened with city
of Bane the death of Alfred and all that
kind of stuff right and so kind of going
after the gunsmith we sort of get a
rundown on this guy this guy's name is
Douglas worth and basically he was a
veteran you know of half a dozen
military contractors as is explained by
James tenyon and then ultimately was
fired from each and every one for using
experimental weapons in the field
without any kind of approval whatsoever
but the reason why he got his name is
that basically he kind of fashioned a
you know a silencer out of different
things that he found from an electronic
store and then killed a guy on a plane
that was full of people and no one knew
that he did it right so he was just that
capable but the issue is that at the end
of the day despite you know his his his
capabilities with fashioning you know
weapons seemingly out of just arbitrary
components kind of kind of being like
this mcgyver sort of situation he's no
match for Batman right so he's taken out
with a quickness right I mean that that
happens quick fast and in a hurry
following that is Mr teeth and Mr teeth
sort of gained his name because of the
fact that what he was doing was going
through and and killing people uh and
then surgically removing the teeth from
their mouth and then surgically putting
them inside their stomachs right now why
he was doing that we don't know probably
because he's just crazy as hell but of
course he's taken out by Batman as well
with a quickness right the other thing
behind this is that they're currently
you know he's currently in the layer of
the uh of of the Riddler and so the
indication seems to be here that these
five guys were basically tasked with
tracking down the classic villains of
Batman Catwoman The Riddler penguin
presumably toofaced The Joker you know
these major members of the criminal
underworld they're each going to take
out one of them and of course Mr teeth
was here to take out the Riddler and so
with Mr teth being removed from the
equation this in turn allows Batman to
basically analyze the the only real
footage left there by Riddler by Edward
nigma which was done of course
intentionally for Batman to follow up on
and it's cool to see that that that
James tenyon does this right it's cool
to see him look at this and say okay
let's still maintain this role of the
Riddler what Edward Nigo was doing is
that when he was confronted by the
designer he was making a series of hand
gestures and these hand gestures were
essentially you know a riddle more or
less on on a keyboard of sorts they were
more or less a riddle and Batman
understanding and deciphering this you
know picking up this riddle is basically
the question what walks on four legs in
the morning two legs in midday and three
legs in the evening and the response to
Lucian Fox is well man I have no idea
how that makes sense but of course you
know Batman figuring it out basically
says okay this essentially grants him
access to the computer systems which
basically shows them that the Riddler
was running a track that that nobody
else was right that Batman wasn't or
anybody else wasn't which was on
Deathstroke and so that of course gives
him the location of Deathstroke which
Batman you know sends out his little bat
drones in order to to track him down but
what this does is that from here it
switches directly over to Batman and to
to Catwoman you know Catwoman and and
Harley Quinn showing up and then
Catwoman basically saying like we need
to talk like we need to have a
conversation I need to tell you about
all of these things you know there is a
guy called the designer that he's
basically here now Batman for the most
part knows what the penguin told him but
he doesn't really know everything and so
it's at this point when Catwoman
apologizes that we get into essentially
the new girlfriend of the Joker a lot of
you guys have been asking about this a
lot of you guys have been asking me
questions what's going on with the
girlfriend of the Joker this is all we
have right this this is it it's
basically just a girl who calls the
Joker and it's just like hey they've
seen the grave but their has been drawn
elsewhere and the Joker's response is
okay like I have something else to
attend to like I mean I have other
people to talk to before this goes down
this is it guys like this is all we have
with the girlfriend of the Joker I don't
really understand why people are
freaking out over it I mean I get it in
so far as it's the Joker's new
girlfriend but aside from this and like
an appearance in Hell Arisen there's
nothing else here right like she's not
going to be a major player until April
or May when it comes to Joker War all
we're going to get is these little
teaser onepage moments and that's
basically going to be it right so this
is kind of kind of strange to me you
know in terms of of of people getting
super hyped up and everybody asking me
about it right it's like people who were
asking me to explain the one below all
in Marvel Comics we don't know
enough we can't explain it because we
don't know enough and we don't really
know anything about her all we know is
that she's just a character who's there
and that's basically it but the big
takeaway from all this is the Joker is
alive right the Joker is very much alive
we don't really know how but the Joker
is very much alive maybe he's one of the
three mysterious Jokers and that's
essentially it
but what's going on guys this is Rob and
we are picking back up again with Batman
and I know it's been a little while
since we covered this been quite some
time since we covered the Batman comics
right but like we need to get caught up
right because there's some some cool
stuff coming down the pipe so for those
of you guys who are playing catchup of
course you'll find the link to the
previous video down in the description
so you can watch that and uh find out
everything that's going on but
effectively What's Happening Here is
James tenyon kind of kicked things off
with his run on Batman following Tom
King uh and he introduced a character
called the designer and we didn't really
know anything about him right and
there's been several videos across
YouTube that have focus on the origin of
the of the character but the designer
was basically a guy who seemingly went
to a handful of criminals and Gotham
City and then basically said like I will
help you guys achieve the goal of
effectively taking the city over for
yourself and this seemed to happen a
number of years ago and so the
implication was that a lot of the
schemes and things that were going on in
the city of Gotham with regards to the
criminals were all based on the efforts
of the designer himself and and what
this basically did is it led to the idea
that the designer seems to have returned
and Batman is kind of caught up in this
whole thing again it's kind of
interesting because it invokes like
Deathstroke and it invokes a few other
characters here and there but we
basically left off with the idea that
Deathstroke's assassins more or less is
henchman for have a better word uh had
basically been taken and then you end up
picking up with Harley Quinn who's
basically controlling a bunch of these
these weapons belonging to Batman and is
sending them after Deathstroke right so
so this part of the story kind of kicks
off you know it picks up with a bang uh
and it's kind of a cool thing because
what it does is it switches back over to
Catwoman and to Bruce Wayne now one of
the things that James tenyon kept going
after the events of Tom King was the
relationship between Catwoman and Bruce
Wayne and a lot of people really like
this right it just kind of made sense
one of the things that always kind of
threw me off about Tom King's writing
was the way that Batman and Catwoman
talk to each other just never really
seemed
organic James tinon really seems to
correct that right Tom King's writing
was a little weird but James tinon
really seems to correct that and
basically giving us this seemingly
organic conversation between the two but
because of the fact that Catwoman was
one of the the initial individuals who
dealt with the designer she's the one
that basically has all this information
and the response of Batman is I need you
to tell me everything that's going on
and so what this does is it gives us a
kind of flashback with the origin of the
designer himself and so far as it's
given to us here and what we basically
learned is that at some point in the
past seemingly around 20 years ago you
know seems to be the the indication the
Catwoman was basically just a kind of
burglar right she was in her in the
early days of her career but there was a
kind of Legend of a guy named the
designer this this individual out there
that was responsible for pulling off
some of the greatest heists that ever
happened it's cool here because he he
was almost kind of like this mythical
enigmatic figure right he existed but
it's one of these things where people
were just kind of like this guy's more
myth than actual fact and so what ended
up happening is that there was basically
a card sent to Catwoman that was
essentially an invitation from from the
designer to meet at a particular
location when she arrives there she's
met by The Riddler she's met by Joker
and she's met by penguin all of whom
have been invited as well and they're
seemingly brought in by this guy on a
boat which is kind of creepy in terms of
how he looks it's almost like crossing
the river sticks right where like you
have to pay the coins to the guy on the
boat I don't remember what his name is
he has an actual name in uh Greek and
Roman Roman theology but uh but
nonetheless they're they're basically
brought to this house right it's called
the house of Tartarus uh where they meet
with the designer for the very first
time and it's kind of nuts here because
the designer sort of pops up and and
really says like when he's talking to
the Joker he's like you're the clown
Prince of Crime like your reputation
precedes you the indication here is that
the designer knows everything about
these guys now when they are brought
here their weapons are basically handed
over to make sure that nothing pops off
but it's kind of a cool thing the other
cool thing about this is the designer
looks amazing right in terms of his
design he looks absolutely awesome but
it's kind of a cool thing because what
we also end up learning is that with
this guy here with with the designer in
his past he had basically come across a
kind of detective and there is more to
the story but we'll figure out you know
what that is later on down the line but
this designer had basically faced off
against this detective and ultimately
found what we basically see with Batman
comics all the time that the villain
fights the good guy and the good guy
always wins because a good guy is always
one or two steps ahead the designer kind
of found himself in this constant
struggle of always losing because the
detective he was fighting was just that
much more intelligent than he was and he
came to the realization that in order to
win he has to outthink the detective
more so than that it can't just be a
plan the detective doesn't expect he has
to be so far ahead that by the time the
detective realizes there's no chance for
him to win he's already lost and
ultimately the designer ended up
spending a year inside of his own
facility right his own kind of base of
operations for lack of a better word and
just kept coming up with all these ideas
and all these plans that were so
Advanced and so nuanced the detective
never saw them coming and the only real
indication we get here is that the
detective was not actually killed by the
designer instead he was left essentially
disgraced right he was left disgraced
and and uh for the most part the world
seems to have lost faith in him and
ultimately he just ended up dying
seemingly of old age but it just ended
up dying me realizing that he was
defeated by what seemed to be either his
greatest foe or any one of the many foes
that he faced off against but the
designer proved to be successful in that
regard and so what it does is it
basically allows the designer to tell
the the various people these various
villains the story and then say I can
help all of you achieve your goal now
it's interesting the way that tenyon
writes this because the villains really
just kind of seem to go along with it
right I mean the reputation of the
designer really seems to kind of
solidify that he's a guy that deserves
to be believed but there's no guarantee
that his reputation is really accurate
outside of the various rumors and here
say that the villains have hurt and so
we're just kind of left to assume that
the designer is is actually correct
right he can do this stuff because his
reputation is such that the individuals
who are telling the story are Beyond
contestation as far as these various
villains are concerned but it is a
pretty cool concept here and so with
Catwoman and with the Riddler and with
penguin meeting with the designer in
turn they all kind of come out really a
lot happier than they were going in
because there seems to be truth to the
idea that the designer can help them
achieve their goals now the whole reason
behind this is the designer can get rich
right he's like I'm going to help all of
you achieve your goals goals but I want
half of all your earnings right I want
half of everything you take and then
we'll just you know you'll never hear
from me again and so finally the
designer meets with the joker and as we
know the Joker is really kind of a wild
card you never really know what's going
to happen and so somehow we we don't
really know what was said but the result
was that when the Joker had his
conversation with the designer the
designer immediately comes out and it's
just like kill them all so whatever the
Joker said piss this guy off nice and
good not only that uh with everything
popping off right like all these all
these forces of the designer coming
after all the various villains who were
here the Joker ends up revealing that he
still has a gun that he kept hidden and
he shoots the designer in the head and
that seems to be the end of him not only
that the various henchmen of the
designer are taken out the Joker
seemingly killed everybody here and it's
kind of nuts because it's like what in
the world could The Joker have possibly
said to this guy that would have led to
this becoming what it was not only that
you also end up having the villains here
saying okay then we're going to sweep
this under the rug this is going to be
our Dirty Little Secret and that's kind
of the secret they were referencing in
the video that we that we did last time
right they all kind of Shar this this
Mutual secret we didn't really know how
deep it went but basically the designer
was the guy who was going to help them
achieve their goals none of their goals
could be achieved without the funding of
the designer which really seemed to be
kind of the plan right like I'll tell
you how you can achieve your goal but
it's all for not if you don't have the
financial backing to do it right the
money to be able to pull it off and so
they have these plans with no means to
achieve them and so they end up kind of
sweeping the whole thing under the rug
but for the Joker himself where they
burn tartar his house and just kind of
leave it there The Joker is kind of
staring off of the distance and that's
when Catwoman comments that she began to
realize how evil The Joker is going to
become because the Joker basically knows
what his plan is he knows what he can do
and the Joker could essentially find a
way to bypass the finances needed by the
designer and then in turn pull it off on
his own anyway not only that when
Catwoman finishes this conversation with
Batman Batman comes to the realization
that the plan of Catwoman was to
basically Rob him her plan was to Rob
Bruce Wayne and so if the designer could
help her achieve that goal then the
designer knew that Batman is Bruce Wayne
not only that the designer knows how to
access his family's wealth meaning
Batman could seemingly lose everything
and so what it does is it switches over
to the Joker you know basically in the
modern day talking to a bartender you
know essentially drinking what looks
like uh looks like a
margarita but he kind of starts telling
the story from his perspective and
basically says that during this meeting
they had with the designer that the
designer basically said I can help you
guys achieve these various goals right
and so ultimately he said like each of
you guys will get a boon you'll
basically get some kind of financial
backing so on and so forth and so
ultimately the the penguin wanted to be
king of Gotham City right he wanted to
be the mayor he wanted to be the one to
run the show The Riddler wanted to be
the smartest person in aam City and
Catwoman wanted to be the wealthiest but
with Joker sitting down and looking at
this and realizing that there would be
no room for the designer in Gotham City
itself The Joker came to the realization
that what the designer intended to do
was help them achieve their goals and
then with nobody else there take them
all out and then seemingly be the only
one to conquer Gotham City or the
indication is that joker was the one who
wanted to do that but basically what he
told the designer is if you're the devil
then I want to take your place I want to
kill you and I want to be the one to
conquer Gotham City and that seems to
have been the reason why why the
designer kind of freaked out because the
Joker was the one that seemed to pick up
on what it was that was actually
happening again this is Joker and the
and the way he tells his stories are
often times ambiguous in the sense that
we don't know if they're ever
true we don't know if he's ever really
telling the truth but again what it does
is it basically picks up with
Deathstroke and Batman on you know
Batman Hot on his Trail the fact that
Harley Quinn is basically kind of
blowing through all the various devices
of Batman and Batman ends up chiming
into lucious Fox and saying like shut
down her control of these things she's
basically spending money like water
through a Civ that's not okay that's the
problem Bruce Wayne ultimately manages
to track down Deathstroke and of course
he ends up taking him captive or at
least you know Deathstroke jumps onto
onto the Batwing and then just starts
like attacking it and so on and so forth
one thing that does happen here is
Catwoman ends up locating Harley Quinn
and then the two of them basically leave
for track down the designer or something
along those lines they're met by a
couple of jokerized members from the
Gotham City Police Department this kind
of seems to be partially a scheme of the
Joker we're not entirely sure here but
what it does it allows a kind of battle
between Batman and Deathstroke now the
reality is that this has kind of been
done to death right Batman versus
Deathstroke but what makes this
interesting is the conversation between
the two because what you end up having
here is Deathstroke and Batman really
having this conversation where Batman
kind of looks around and says like down
there in Gotham City there's 9 million
people and ironically enough their faith
in their government actually went up
when Bane took control it it's one of
these interesting things we talked about
that in the city of Bane story AR like
people would say God you know it's
terrible that Bane took over Gotham and
all that kind of stuff but at the end
according to the people there he made
the city a better place that Batman's
not really willing to do what it takes
in order to actually win this battle
that's the interesting thing about the
Batman Mythos is I hear people kind of
create these arguments all the time of
like well if that were the logic then
like Superman should kill his villains
and Spider-Man should kill his villains
and so on and so forth but Batman
categorically and unequivocally has the
worst most violent Rogues Gallery in all
of comic books and that's why there's a
legitimate case to make there in saying
that Batman should kill all his villains
right because the city of Gotham would
be better off with all those various
villains debt it's cool because Batman
kind of looks at this and says yeah like
this city is the way it is because of me
and and it's one of these things where
he almost kind of tries to play it based
on like well you know I mean my parents
died when I was a little kid they were
shot in an alley and and I was I had to
go down this path and all this kind of
stuff and death stroke's not buying it
he's like at the end of the day man you
can you can come to me whatever story
you want to but you escalated we were
criminals doing criminal things you're
the one who dawned a cloak and cowl and
then you're the one that started taking
us out the way that you did we had to
step up because you stepped up you're
sort of left asking the question right
if Bruce Wayne becoming Batman is what
led to criminals becoming more violent
then is Batman really the reason why
Gotham is the way it is were criminals
ever going to become that that violent
in the first place or did they only ever
really get that way because of Batman
it's interesting to look at it for the
other you know from the other side of
the equation and so Batman tries to
reason with Deathstroke and it's like
look I'm trying to change the fact that
I've gotten extreme in recent years
because he has Batman's become more and
more Extreme as Comics have gone on you
look at like Silver age Batman and then
you compare him to like Batman from like
Infinite Crisis final crisis the new 52
Batman's gotten more and more extreme
over the years because remember it's all
just one cohesive continuity now right
so Batman has gotten more extreme over
the years and where he's like I'm trying
to change this extreme nature but what I
need you guys to do is to basically slow
down and stop the response to
Deathstroke is no that's not going to
happen right like we're not going to
slow down we're not going to stop and so
Batman basically like just lunges at him
and sends both of them flying off the
Batwing and ultimately Deathstroke cses
Bluff right he's like look man you can
do this all day long if you want to but
we both know you're going to shoot one
of your your bat grappling guns right so
just do that do the damn thing and then
save us right and that's exactly what he
does right he shoots a grappling hook
and basically ends up saving him and
Deathstroke and that's essentially it
and and it's it's kind of a funny thing
because Deathstroke can essentially play
Batman like a fiddle Batman's
predictable there's just a line that
Batman won't cross and because the
villains know Batman won't cross that
line at the end of the day he's always
only ever a half measure because it's
kind of like I won't do what needs to be
done in order to save Gotham City
because I don't believe in killing right
my parents were killed and you know yada
yada Y and and so on and so forth but
sometimes it's in the best interest to
kill a villain right it's it's in the in
the interest of people by Batman not
killing his villains all he's doing is
sacrificing innocent lives right he's
saying like the thousands of people that
B that that joker is going to kill over
the course of a year or several years or
something like that they are not as
valuable as the Joker's life right the
Joker being redeemed is more valuable
than those innocent people and that's
why it's always an interesting question
how many lives is Batman willing to
sacrifice before he says enough is
enough because in the end if he has the
means to kill the Joker but he doesn't
he is in effect sacrificing those
people's lives and so where the the
designer finally pops up to Batman and
basically says you know Deathstroke
you're done now indicating to
Deathstroke that he's going to get
screwed over on his contract Batman's
kind of like you know come and face me
and the response to the designer is no
we still have one more game left and
that's when Edward nigma The Riddler
pops up and says the entirety of Gotham
City is now under my control I've split
the entire city into what's basically a
giant crossw word puzzle and there's
these enormous walls as tall as
buildings you know and it's like
everybody stay put where you are the
only way the entire city is going to be
let loose uh is if Batman's able to
correctly Sol solve this crossword
puzzle if he guesses wrong then I
basically blow up a bomb right and the
indication here is that if he guesses
like three across and like four down and
he gets it wrong that section gets
destroyed with a bomb and so lives are
lives are basically in Jeopardy here
this is the kind of thing I'm talking
about right like this wouldn't be a
problem if Edward nigma were
dead and so it's it's it's it's kind of
interesting because ultimately Lucius
Fox cannot really locate where Edward
nigma is where the Riddler is and nigma
just starts cutting off Batman's
Communications in order to force him in
a situation where he has to use his own
wits in order to be able to pull this
off and it's kind of cool because this
is an insane amount of huus on behalf of
the Riddler because we're this kind of
starts going down Batman ends up of
course taking uh taking Deathstroke
who's currently handcuffed and then
takes him to like a Batman
train literally Batman has a bat train
and so while that's happening while
Batman's facing off against these these
forces of uh of the designer who were
seemingly kind of coming out of nowhere
and waiting on this train to arrive then
you end up having Riddler who's asking
these questions right one across nine
spaces the more I I take the more I
leave behind Batman's response footsteps
Joker comes in eight down five spaces
what has many keys but can open no doors
Batman's response piano he's answering
all these things like that right just
off the top of his head and this is
James Tenon really showing the
intelligence of Bruce Wayne this is one
of the most important aspects and it's
one of the coolest things right because
like when you look at sny's Batman run
what made what really showcased Bruce
Wayne's intelligence was the small
things right now some of that was
because it's Batman comics Batman can't
die because you know he's just too
popular for DC to kill off he just sells
too well right and so that's why Batman
always comes out on top but to see a
display of his intelligence like this
just constantly countering Edward nous
questions every every time he asks a
scenario Batman basically answers almost
perfectly right 10 across 11 spaces a
woman shoots her husband holds him
underwater for 5 minutes hangs him and
then takes him out to dinner how was
that possible the response of Batman
photography she took a picture of him
right being able to like counter every
single one of Edward nigma's riddles off
the top of his head with the greatest of
ease despite being completely batt ble
worn and totally exhausted shows how far
above Edward nigma Batman really is and
that's where nigma starts getting pissed
off and that was always his weakness
right in comics that was always the
weakness of Edward nigma he would let
his temper get the better of him if
Batman started getting the better of him
it was just kind of it was it was always
the thing that ended up catching him off
guard now from here this picks up with
Catwoman and Harley Quinn in a pretty
interesting scenario right we end up
finding out what it is that that Harley
Quinn and Catwoman are actually up to
and in reality it's just Catwoman Harley
Quinn's just kind of along for the ride
but we end up finding out that what
Catwoman is looking for is someone
called the under broker and this is an
individual who basically has access to
essentially every bank account across
the entirety of Gotham City you can you
can access anybody's account using the
help of this particular guy now Catwoman
says that she has the account numbers
that she's a member of their Club in
good standing and this basically leads
to Catwoman being allowed in by the
under broker himself the issue with this
is that as Catwoman gets in there
they're meant by the arrival of
punchline the punch line is actually
there not only that this is when Harley
Quinn meets the Joker's new girlfriend
for the very first time and it is cool
cuz Harley Quinn doesn't initially know
that instead it's just kind of like
punchline is like I'm here to make a
withdrawal too I'm the punchline I'm
where you end it's kind of a lame phrase
to
have but it is is a cool thing to see
them encounter each other because when
when Harley Quinn's like who in the
world is this person Catwoman's like
she's the Joker's new girlfriend and
Harley's like oh this girl's in for a
time you would think Harley Quinn would
be pissed about being replaced right
like oh no no no no let me tell you
something Harley Quinn is often imitated
never
duplicated that's not the response right
that's that's not what happens instead
Harley is kind of like okay so like
you're in for a rough ride like I know
it seems cool to be the Joker's new
girlfriend at the moment he's going to
screw you up in ways that you can't even
begin to imagine yet not only that
Harley's whole thing is like are you
funny cuz you don't really sound funny
and like punchline tries to make a few
sort of veiled threats and outright
threats and tries to make a few jokes
here and there but at the end of the day
Harley's not buying it she's like I've
been around this block more than a few
times you got nothing you got nothing no
jokes no puns no anything you are a poor
man's Harley Quinn and she basically
tells her like in a few years and a few
dozen cries in the shower and so on and
so forth I'm going to buy you a frozen
margarita and we're going to have a girl
tog girl chat about how you made the
worst decision of your life but until
then I'm going to bash your head in with
a
hammer and immediately attacks the girl
I love that not only that of course
Catwoman ends up getting her hand on the
under broker and then we end up finding
out you know who this guy is right that
his name is Haren Graves this guy has
all kinds of information but Catwoman
knows everything about him as well and
so it's like if you if you don't tell me
what I want to know I'm going to start
spewing all your private information for
Harley Quinn and for punchline to hear
and if you don't want me to do that
you're going to take me to a computer
terminal to get me where I need to go
the reality and what seems to be going
on here is that if the designer does
have the plan of Catwoman which was to
Rob Bruce Wayne and seemingly has sent
punchline for that purpose to access
that computer terminal and of course
Catwoman is there to basically withdraw
those funds or to move those funds to a
different location so that the the
designer can't get his hands on him
right so Bruce Wayne doesn't lose
everything and so with that being the
case Batman ends up tracking down the
Riddler after he recognizes where it is
the Riddler's at he takes out the
Riddler right it's not a great big H
thing Riddler is not really physically
capable in comparison to Batman the
Riddler's taken out pretty quickly
Batman basically knocks out Deathstroke
with a tranquilizer dart that's enough
to keep an elephant asleep for a few
hours so on Deathstroke it'll probably
work for like half an hour 45 minutes
you know because of his healing factor
and so Batman is basically kind of met
by the arrival of the designer who says
you know it's cool you've unraveled all
your adversaries designs that's awesome
but it's not going to be enough because
you must know that if I'm in Bruce
Wayne's office then it means I must know
who you are and the designer confirms
that in saying hello Bruce Wayne it's
time that you and I have a conversation
before I kill you what's going on guys
this is Rob and we are back again with
Batman the conclusion of their dark
designs and you guys really seem to love
the video where Harley Quinn met the
Joker's new girlfriend you guys really
seem to enjoy that video so in this one
uh we kind of get the the the end of it
all right you know the the the end of
the whole whole thing or at least the
conclusion kind of starts to kick off
now this does go into Joker War which is
kind of the next big storyline in the
Batman Mythos that that DC's kicking
around I have no idea if it's going to
tie into like the three Jokers the
storyline that was teased to us like two
years ago we just never got because
hashtag reasons no idea but regardless
uh for those of you guys who recall our
last video we basically picked up with
Batman encountering the designer right
and the idea was that the designer had
somehow returned it seemed that he'd
been killed by The Joker or at least by
well really by The Joker and then along
with the other villains who more or less
kind of turned against him but but you
know the fact that the designer's here
now really kind of gives us a
perspective into what's going on because
what you get here is Batman basically
telling the designer tell me how this
goes right give me this scenario and the
designer's response is no like if you've
already deduced it then you tell me what
happens and so we kind of get this big
explanation in terms of how it was all
supposed to go down right so this is how
the designer's plan was originally going
to unfold in the city of Gotham before
everything went belly up with a joker
and all those guys right so initially
the idea was to bring in five of the
highest paid assassins the best paid
assassins and the whole world right and
at that point in time back then when
this was all kind of brought together
initially right because the actual plan
of the designer took place in the past
uh it would have been uh Deathstroke
Deadshot Lady Shiva kg beast and Merlin
now the whole idea behind them was to
basically launch a simultaneous attack
all at once in the city of Gotham not
against the entirety of the city's
populace but instead against those
individuals who would basically be in
the line of succession when it comes to
the fall of the mayor right so you'd
have the mayor who would be taken out
the deputy mayor the public Advocate the
city comp trol and the majority leader
of the city council right so they would
all be taken out in one Fell Swoop just
all seemingly happening in almost an
instant this would lead to Batman
basically jumping in and starting to
investigate but what it would also lead
to is the Penguin basically becoming
mayor of Gotham City now as the mayor
this in turn would move to the Riddler
and The Riddler would lock down the
entirety of the city of Gotham but what
he would do here is he would operate on
two fronts the first front would be a
ruse it would basically be well there
you know riddle me this and all the
puzzles and all that kind of stuff the
truth about it was to basically basally
isolate the NYPD precincts and then only
those individual police officers who
were basically willing to come forward
and swear loyalty to the Riddler would
be allowed to navigate from one location
to the next but what it would do is it
would lock down entire precincts and it
would make it easy to take out a
multitude of different cops right
because if you don't have to worry about
police officers running all over the
place going underground hiding different
things like that you can just start
taking them out in huge chunks other
precincts don't know what are happening
to other precincts because all lines of
communication are effectively cut off it
would make it E easy to basically take
control of the entire police uh the
entire police force or at least get rid
of those who were who are not loyal and
keep those who were loyal this goes into
Catwoman and because Catwoman would be
the one that would basically be dealing
with the money she would effectively
hack into all the various accounts of
the richest man in Gotham City Bruce
Wayne and she would come to the
realization that the Wayne Foundation is
actually funded by offshore accounts and
the way this would work is she would
basically have all those different
account numbers in hand she would drain
all those assets and then redistribute
them accordingly based on whatever the
plan calls for but what it would do is
it would basically make her the richest
woman in all of Gotham and then in turn
she would be the bank for all the
various criminals that are out there the
place where they can they can save their
money they can put their money there and
then using those various offshore
accounts she can run those run that
money offshore and keep it hidden away
from everybody this finally goes into
the Joker and the Joker's task was
simple The Joker would kill Batman and
Robin it's the only thing that he would
do right it seemed to be the only thing
the Joker really wanted to do and with
all of that happening the designer
essentially would allow the various
criminals to take out and really conquer
the entirety of Gotham City in one Fell
Swoop it would happen almost overnight
right it would happen so fast before
Batman even realized what was going on
when he first began the process of
investigating they would be miles ahead
of it right they'd be almost done with
their plan by the time he first started
his investigation into what was going on
now a lot of that was based on Batman's
inexperience at the time the fact that
he wasn't that great of a superhero I
mean he was but in terms of his
detective skills he's learned a lot over
the time that he's been operating as a
superhero and so to cap capitalize on
that lack of experience would allow the
designer's plan to come to fruition and
so ultimately Batman's response is you
know I'm not the man that I was like I
have evolved I caught up to your design
and I am equal to it now and so this
leads to the two of them getting into a
kind of sword fight of sorts now this
jumps back over to to Catwoman and
Catwoman coming to this realization that
that kind of going through and and
accessing these different accounts that
the Wayne Foundation is actually funded
through offshore accounts and it seems
pretty shady right because the way that
it looks for for anybody out there the
way that it looks is there's just a
whole bunch of other corporations out
there companies out there who were all
basically working alongside Wayne
foundation and they're probably looked
at as like subsidiaries or something
like that but basically Bruce Wayne
himself doesn't really seem to own
anything in reality it's all money
that's owned by uh by Wayne Enterprises
but this is also beneficial because with
Bruce Wayne being a person who operates
as a superhero operating as Batman he
doesn't want anybody to know how that
money is being spent and the truth is
that if there was a breadcrumb digitally
or physically in terms of actual Hard
Cash somebody would come looking right
somebody would be able to trace that
that that breadcrumb and then ultimately
draw the conclusion the accurate
conclusion that Bruce Wayne is Batman
and so in order to remove any
possibility of him being tied to how the
money is being spent with regards to
things going that that basically Batman
would use uh is kind of a it's using a
series of shell companies in order to
hide it and so it's kind of a funny
thing because Catwoman for the most part
knows all this right now the under
broker the person who's you know who's
who's well really she's not really doing
it of his he's not doing of his own
volition like she's basically told him
that she was going to dump his identity
if he didn't help her uh but this guy
has no idea that Bruce Wayne is Batman
right in his mind it's just this guy's
probably up to some she uh some some CD
stuff and that's basically it but
regardless the response of Catwoman is
we're going to drain all these accounts
right like you're going to drain all
those accounts and you're going to put
them in in my account right you're
basically going to put these accounts in
my name and I am going to become the
richest person in Gotham now keep in
mind Catwoman isn't doing this in order
to to take revenge on Batman she's doing
this to ensure that Bruce Wayne can
remain Batman and not lose all of his
money right that's that's the really the
the only reason why she's doing this at
this point remember you know her stance
on the whole plan and everything all has
kind of changed over the years and so
following this what we do is we jump to
probably what you guys want to see most
which is Harley Quinn versus punchline
now punchline we don't really know much
about her history her origin or anything
like that but the way that she fights
Harley Quinn really seems to show that
she's a pretty top-notch fighter she's
by no means prodigious right because
Harley Quinn's not the greatest fighter
there ever was right fighting her is not
like fighting Deathstroke or somebody
like that but at the end of the day you
know she's you know having this
conversation with punchline talking to
her punchline basically saying that like
at the end of the day Harley Quinn
wanted to fix him she wanted to make him
better right she wanted to water him
down basically into nothing uh that
ultimately punchline looks at Joker for
the way he is and is in love with it and
so the response of Harley Quinn is
you're a groupy you're basically a joker
groupy but the the idea behind punchline
is that it's it's not really about that
right it's not really about any kind of
physical gratification that she gets
from being with the joker if there even
is any what makes him so interesting to
her is that the Joker could conquer
Gotham City and Harley Quinn could have
been there for the entire ride but she
didn't want the Joker for the way he was
she wanted the wanted the Joker for the
way she wanted him to be now that wasn't
initially how it all went down right
Holley Quinn was initially in love with
the joker right that's one of the the
many origins of her character but the
long and short of it is that she always
in some form or fashion was enamored by
The Joker the role he played the way he
saw the world all that kind of stuff and
where she was kind of swept up in that
it wasn't until she began to really see
what the Joker was about that she
started to see that she was better off
without him and so as time began to
began to progress you started seeing
these stories in in uh in DC Comics
where Harley Quinn would leave the Joker
she'd go off and do her own thing the
Joker would run would basically run her
out like he would kick her out she'd go
and do her own thing whatever the case
was she kind of began this process of
separating herself from The Joker more
and more often until eventually she just
walked away right she just basically
left the Joker in his entirety and he
just been operating solo that entire
time but it's kind of crazy because one
of the funny things is that punchline
seems to be highly enamored the same way
that Harley Quinn was and she even goes
as far as to say that like the Joker
says I'm the funniest person he knows
well the response of Harley who's been
around this block more than a few times
is like yeah but he says that to
everybody right like he said that to
Batman he said it to to an old nun who
couldn't talk anymore like he's the
Joker he jokes like that's what he does
right so if you're really buying into to
what he's telling you as an absolute
truth then you're an idiot like he's a
bad guy right like he's a villain and
and the response to punch line is maybe
he is you know and maybe he will hurt me
one day but I'm going to hurt you first
she manages to get the upper hand on
Harley and then slices her throat
following that they toss her body into
the water and then she in turn starts to
go after starts to go after Catwoman
it's kind of crazy to see punchline take
out Harley Quinn that way but picking
back up with Batman and the designer
again the two of them sort of go at it
and and continuing to fight so on and so
forth one of the things that Batman
figures out is that the designer had
underestimated Gotham City right that
the designer believed he could just kind
of roll in here and basically start
pitching these ideas to these various
criminals on ways in which they could
topple Batman and Robin and then take
the city for themselves but the reality
is that the designer underestimated The
Joker and he underestimated Gotham City
given this plan and the nature of what
it is that he wanted to do at the end of
the day it would only really work if
Joker was willing to kill Batman and
Robin but the truth is the Joker didn't
want to he wanted to kill everybody else
but he didn't want to kill Batman and
Robin and it scared the crap out of the
designer because the Joker couldn't be
explained he couldn't be rationalized
right he couldn't be categorized he
wasn't somebody that was just based on
simple a simple desire to to acquire
money or anything like that right like
it's like The Dark Knight he just wants
to watch the world burn and that's
really what the designer didn't grasp
when the when the designer first showed
up here he thought the Joker was just a
petty serial killer right and like
appeals to his to his vanity or to his
desire to acquire wealth or to Vengeance
by taking out Batman and Robin would be
all he really needed to be on board but
when the Joker was was brought in by the
designer and the designer learned what
the Joker was really about that he was
really just a Madman he was an
absolutely insane person he didn't care
about the identity of Bruce Wayne and
Robin I'm sorry of Batman and Robin he
didn't care who they really were he
didn't care about killing them that in
fact he wanted to keep them alive and
just make them suffer by killing
everybody else the designer realized he
was beyond any real ability to be
reasoned with and so ultimately this
cost the designer his life and when
Batman pulls off the mask the designer
is actually dead right he's he's
basically just kind of like this
shambling shell as Batman refers to it
and ultimately he's being controlled by
the Joker and that's when Batman asked
the question what are you doing like why
attack me like this what are you trying
to prove now Batman had figured out the
Joker was controlling the designer
seemingly some time ago there's not
really an indication of that's if that's
actually true but probably partway
through this fight he seemed to figure
it out and the response of the Joker is
like it's not my plan to break you right
that's what comes next like I have a
whole year to do that right so you know
obviously teasing Joker War but his
whole idea is I needed to break her in
order to break you right so in turn like
Batman realizes it's Catwoman that he's
going after and so immediately
Deathstroke jumps in right Deathstroke
was tasked by The Joker for completing a
task Deathstroke man managed to sneak
into this place or managed to get into
this place with Batman distracted and in
that moment stabs him through the leg
with a sword and normally it wouldn't
really matter but the idea here is that
if Batman pulls it out he's going to
bleed to death right so he basic he's
basically kind of stuck here at the
moment and he has to figure out what it
is that he needs to do next right like
some kind of a medic is going to have to
be sent over here by by Lucius Fox there
is no Alfred anymore right so it's not
like Alfred contend to his wounds or
anything so Batman's got to figure out
what to do and in that time he needs to
figure out what it is that he needs to
do that allows the Joker's plan to
continue going and that's the benefit of
all this right it's not really the
grandiose nature of the plan that
provides its success it's the precious
moments in between each step that
provides success right the fact that
Batman has to stop and figure out what
he's going to do for like five 5 or 10
minutes is all the time that joker needs
to achieve a particular goal that's
really what you're talking about here
right as fast as the mind of Bruce Wayne
works his ability to react almost
instantly right what ever that case is
this means that the Joker has to be able
to respond accordingly and all this
stuff seems to have been prepared for
and so switching back to Catwoman once
this is all done and Catwoman's work is
finished and all this money has been
transferred to essentially another
external account then the response of
Catwoman is remove all my information
right delete all my account information
all of it has to go and and at the end
of the day the response of the under
broker is well I mean your account like
your account is is actually quite empty
right like you believ you were
transferring all this information to
your account and you believe that what
we were going to do now was remove your
account from this database so nobody
else could access it but there's nothing
sent to your account your account's dead
because you were never sending money to
your account in the first place with
that happening there's a gunshot we end
up finding out punchline pulled the
trigger Catwoman is essentially down for
the count and then in turn she calls the
Joker and the Joker asks the question is
it done and she says yes and the Joker
says say it I want to hear these words
and the response is Joker you are now
worth over $100
billion all right guys we are here with
the finale of dark designs really it's
not even the finale it's the beginning
of the Joker War right I love how this
is being done right here's here's the
thing I love what James tenon's doing
with Batman right it's the best thing
coming out of what used to be DC
rebirth I love what he's doing with
Batman uh I was I was a fan of Tom
King's run I would say that that this
whole thing dark designs is an amazing
story right I would say this follows
very closely the Snider's Batman run if
that gives you any indication but what
this does here is this initially picks
up with Bruce Wayne in his younger years
and Bruce Wayne is more or less just
kind of waiting on a guy like wait just
sitting kind of sitting at a table doing
these little designs of Gotham City it's
kind of funny because he basically says
they were they were never really a
design for the city uh the dark designs
were always for him right uh but he
ultimately ends up basically you know
tracking this guy down finding him and
then basically following him and and
he's he basically tells him look like I
followed your Clues uh I know you're in
there like I know who you are uh you
know I need to talk to you and
ultimately you know Bruce Wayne kind of
makes his way in and this guy basically
says or at least Bruce reveals this
guy's name is cassander wlef Baker now
for those of you guys who are following
our story or at least following the dark
designs this guy was the Nemesis of the
designer right the the guy that that the
designer basically spent all this time
trying to track down at Le trying to
defeat spent years and years and years
in a room creating a plan so that by the
time this guy Baker figured out what was
going on the plan was already almost
done right and Baker's days were were
essentially finished the other funny
thing about this too is that Baker
basically you know indicates he knows
who Bruce Wayne is right he knows
exactly who he is which isn't really the
biggest thing in the world right it's
like from Batman Begins that like Bruce
Wayne would have to he'd have to tr
travel 2,000 miles to find somebody who
didn't know his name but the the the way
that James chion really kind of hits on
this to really show how good of a
detective this guy is is he says like I
can tell from the cut of your jacket
which Port of Japan you traveled here
from right I can tell you uh where you
learned the art of the katana right I
can tell you where you were when you
learn how to how to slow your heartbeat
I know all these things about you right
the cut of your hair tells me where you
learn how to fly the calluses on your
hand tell me where you learn to forge
metal like I know all these things about
you I know everything about you just by
looking at you that's how good this
Detective was right that's how good
Baker was he could take one Glimpse at
Bruce Wayne and then say I know
everywhere you've been within the last
you know however long and when Bruce as
how could you possibly know Baker kind
of reveals this secret room where he he
has like all these pictures all over the
place right and it's kind of like this
this is everything I know about this
place right everything I know about you
everything I know about everything I've
seen all kinds of stuff and he says I'm
going to teach you the most important
lesson I'm not going to teach you how to
be a detective I'm going to teach you
how to lose and that's a super important
thing here and on the surface it's easy
for for you to kind of be like okay
that's weird right and to kind of write
it off no it's it's not necessarily
important to win it's important to know
how to lose because if you know how to
lose you know how to understand why you
lost you know how to correct the reason
you lost and then you know how to win
because the reality of this is you don't
win 100% of the time right it's like
that line from Oceans 11 right like
because the house always takes you right
no matter how long you play if you play
long enough the house wins unless when
that perfect hand comes along you bet
big and then you take the house that's
basically what this is right it's Batman
being taught at a very young age you're
going to lose it's going to happen right
it's inevitable but what you have to
learn is how to recover from that loss
and how to go forward accordingly and so
what we end up doing is picking up in
the immediate aftermath of the last
video that we covered right the last
comic where basically Batman was stabbed
through the leg by Deathstroke now a lot
of people kind of looked at it as though
it was some kind of a joke right like
Batman stabbed to the leg you know
what's the case it's not just a random
leg stabbing right like death stroke hit
an artery now technically if he really
wanted to kill Batman in 30 seconds he
would have stabbed him in that artery
right down there in the groin right
right you'll bleed out like that right
it it'll take no time at all but he
stabbed him in a location where it's
like one of these things if you pull it
out you're going to bleed to death and
that's why Lucius Fox was basically
contacted to get in here because it
brought Deathstroke time right it
brought Deathstroke the time he needed
to basically leave right so Lucius Fox
has to get here Batman's not going to go
anywhere he's not going to go running
out because any major movement he makes
takes the risk of of you know
exacerbating this this stab or this this
injury with this sword so he's going to
have to just wait until Lucius gets
there then Lucius is going to do
whatever he has to do not a medic right
he's not Alfred he's not a trained
doctor right so he's going to do
whatever he can and then there's a time
for Batman to recover however long it
takes for him to recover that buys
Deathstroke a breadth of time and when
you're talking about a scenario like
this all Deathstroke really needs is
like half an hour to 45 minutes and he's
on the other he's he's on a plane gone
out of Gotham City and who knows where
he's at and this is also singularly more
important because while Batman wouldn't
normally have the resources to tr track
Deathstroke down if you wanted to
remember all those resources are gone
now right so you end up having basically
Lucius Fox who who kind of just throws
like a compression bandage more or less
uh onto you know onto onto Batman which
does enough to kind of keep the keep him
from bleeding out all over the place you
know it's more or less just kind of like
taking your hand and covering over the
wound and putting pressure on it that's
all it really does it's a stop Gap
measure right the response is like Bruce
you have to go to a hospital and get
some kind of surgery done or something
like that because if you don't you're
just going to bleed out and so what
Lucius does is immediately start
dropping all this information right like
Batman tells Lucius like they have my
they have the fortune now right Joker
has all my account numbers all that
information he's got everything about me
and the response of Lucius is yeah I
know lawyers have already seized your
house like you're you're wanted for
embezzling millions of dollars which we
know Bruce Wayne was doing or at least
that seemed to be the case that like
Bruce was funling money he was
embezzling money out of the company into
foreign accounts and Wayne Enterprises
itself was doing that running through
foreign Banks Bruce Wayne's wanted for
all of that right so he's wanted by the
law his Fortune's gone he has nothing
right it's just like there's really
nothing he can do and the response of
Lucius Fox is I would love to be in your
corner the way that Alfred was I'd love
to be the guy who would be here and help
you every step of the way but if I'm
going to fight this off I have to
operate as the CEO of of Wayne
Enterprises I can only keep them at Bay
for so long so I can't be in your corner
I have to go take care of this right and
it's one of these things where he says
if I was Alfred sure I'd be able to do
that right because Alfred was a Swiss
army knife Alfred did everything but I'm
not Alfred pennyworth I'm Lucius Fox and
all I can do is the best that I can do
and so in turn you have Batman who asks
where's Selena Kyle right you think he
would have asked that already because
it's the woman he's going to marry but
he's like wor Selena Kyle and the
response to Lucius is she was shot she's
in a Hospital uh and then he's just like
give like like I want to talk to her
right now where Lucius is a little
hesitant about that focusing more on the
health of Batman that he's getting ready
to pass out you know Batman's like I
don't want to hear any of it I want to
talk to Selena Kyle and this basically
leads to Lucius kind of putting his
daughter on the phone who put Selena on
the phone and Selena's kind of in and
out of Consciousness right she's barely
making it she's just slightly
unconscious and it's one of these things
where where Batman kind of hits at where
he feels like he fell short right where
he feel where he feels like he kind of
screwed up it's one of the great things
tenon's focused on here and it's one of
the elements that's Fallen under the the
radar right there was this really really
good moment when Batman confronted
Deathstroke and they were kind of going
back and forth in this argument and
Deathstroke was like you were the one
who who like like you stepped it up
first right like you were the one that
made things worse first we were
criminals who were doing things you
stepped it up against us right like you
exacerbated the situation and Batman's
response was yes I know and that's
really kind of how Bruce Wayne was right
that Bruce Wayne was a a kid who whose
parents were shot in front of him and
he's been crying about it his whole life
and he ended up going through all these
different training sessions learning all
these different things and when he came
back to Gotham City he didn't meet with
an equal force he met with overwhelming
Force right he hammered him it's like
what was it the dark knight uh the The
Dark Knight film he hammered and
hammered and hammered all these
different guys to the point of
desperation he's the one that made
things worse that instead of responding
to them with an adequate Force he
responded with more than what he needed
and that's what made things worse in
Gotham City it was Batman's actions that
pushed people further and further and
it's what made things more and more
extreme not only that he you know
because of the life he lived because of
the person that he was he systematically
pushed away everybody that cared about
him right everybody that mattered to him
he pushed every single one of them away
and it led him to where he is right now
this was not the life Selena Kyle was
banking on Selena Kyle joined up with
Batman because she was expecting a
better life she was expecting things to
improve but Batman made them worse and
so the result of this is that he
basically says like I'm going to go and
I'm going to try to clean this up and
I'm going to try to make sure
everything's sorted out you know
hopefully you can forgive me and
hopefully you'll be here when I get back
but he's like I'll just I'll kind of be
waiting on you and in his anger and in
his Rampage of course he smashes a
window but lucious Fox is kind of
shocked to hear the Batman's actually
going to go out right he's got he's got
a a stab in his leg where he's just
bleeding out but he's going to go out
there and continue to fight anyway it's
one of these things where Batman's
making a stupid choice he's making a
stupid decision that he seems to kind of
be overcome with emotion but the reality
of this is when he kind of chimes in and
he says Lucius it's not just Vengeance
here it's not me just pissed off because
my money was taken and I'm really really
mad he's like there's a bigger picture
at play here the Joker has all my
resources he has everything that Batman
had he's got all the Batmobiles he's got
all everything in way manner he's got
all the money he's got all the
technology everything that I use in
order to function as Batman is now in
possession of the Joker so here's what
you're going to do you're you're one
you're going to call up Leslie Tomkins
who most of you guys know is the one
that basically she's kind of like the
the Night Nurse from Marvel Comics right
she's the one that basically runs a free
clinic where she tends to the injuries
of various Heroes some villains
depending on what the situation is and
then he basically says like what you are
about to see in the city of Gotham is
going to be an attack from The Joker and
it's going to be like nothing we've ever
seen before right because this is not
the Joker flooding the city with Joker
toxin like he did during ingame it's
nothing like that this is Joker on a
whole new level it's the Joker with
advanced technology and with Insanity
who in the hell knows what he's going to
do right and so you kind of switch over
to to the Deathstroke for a moment and
this is kind of a quick throwaway thing
and it's easy to ignore but it's
massively significant because you've got
got Deathstroke talking to Lady Shiva
and or I guess Cheshire is really what
her name is but uh but but you know
she's kind of like nobody here they're
all kind of pissed off that they were
used and Strokes like I don't really
care you know they were getting paid
well for it and when she asks like what
are you doing he just says like 9
million people and she's like what and
he's like I'm just taking one last look
and like literally looking at this city
of 9 million people which is about to
devolve into absolute chaos and
pandemonium switch over to Batman who
goes to get Catwoman because he knows
Joker is going to start coming after
everybody when he gets there she's gone
he has no idea where where Catwoman's
gone to she's just vanished now
initially the implication was the
Joker's henchmen showed up and snatched
her up no the Joker's henchmen are there
and they're like it was a smart move
getting rid of Catwoman so they don't
know where Catwoman is and and where
where they kind of make this off-handed
remark of you know I doubt the boss
would care if we had some some Crossfire
some casualties and they ask him and
Joker's on the phone and he's like no I
really wouldn't mind I'm in such a good
mood go ahead and take out a whole floor
if you want to right and and where
Batman asked the Joker do you have
Catwoman he says no no no she bailed the
second that she was stitched up right
she saw this coming man I don't know why
you didn't but she saw this coming right
like maybe she knows your real Bays back
in town who knows but whatever the
reason is she's out of here right like
she basically ended up taking off and
that's when the Joker starts to taunt
Batman he's like oh you're bleeding out
you got to go and get yourself stitched
up man because with the war that I'm
going to bring you I want you at 100%
because I want you to know that when you
lost to me you didn't lose because of
some technicality you didn't lose
because you weren't functioning at full
capacity I want you to know you lost to
me when you were at your best right I
have your money I have your house I have
your company The Joker Is like an
ex-wife right like I have your house
your car your company I have the kids I
have it all I have the dog hell I even
took the Goldfish like it's it's it's
nuts right the Joker's like I have
everything of yours man I have
everything that belongs to you I'm going
to take all these toys that you've been
building in Wayne Enterprises I'm going
to take all these things and I'm going
to use them right like for years and
years and years you've been fighting me
and I've been using the resources of an
abandoned Toy Factory well guess what
that's not the case anymore man you're
totally alone you have none of your
resources you have none of your money
you have nothing at your side you've got
no family you've got no girlfriend
you've got no Butler you are absolutely
and totally categorically alone it
doesn't look very good for you that's
what's so crazy because the Joker is
like I've got designs for this city man
I've got designs for everything I'm
going to tear this city from the ground
up and I'm going to rebuild it all and
you're going to be the one that pays for
it all he says so let's get this started
he says Boys fire they open City on
Batman just starts spraying down Batman
jumps out of a window you immediately
switchs to Catwoman right she wakes up
kind of seemingly out of the middle of
nowhere and we find out she was rescued
by the penguin that the penguin's like
man this like this is this is a pretty
wild situation like it's it's initially
you know she kind of says well you know
when when he asks about the designer she
says the designer's dead right Joker's
been playing us this entire time and and
the Penguin's like okay like you're you
know I can let you into the private
Lounge this private Lounge is called the
cool room right this whole place
basically houses and it's actually so
cool to see the Mad Hatter again I
haven't seen him in a while uh but it it
houses basically almost all of Batman's
villains right and the response to the
Joker is like this place is basically a
safe house that when things pop off this
is where we go like when things are bad
enough the whole City's in Jeopardy this
is where we basically kind of hang out
at until things get terrible I don't see
kitan which really kind of sucks right I
love to see kitan hell yeah but
nonetheless uh you know when when
Catwoman says like I need to get out of
here the response of the penguin is
that's not possible this entire place is
in lockdown right it's a joker attack
which is kind of wild right to hear that
like when the Joker decides to attack
Gotham City this is how all the villains
react right there's no like holding the
Joker off it's like okay guys let's all
go into lockdown let's go underground
you know the penguin says hundreds of
people probably even thousands are going
to die we're sitting this one out right
so like Buckle in Catwoman it's going to
be a long bloody summer it's nuts and so
you end up switching back over to Batman
who's just kind of musing to himself
right talking about everything that he
had learned from Alfred how Alfred
always wanted him to strive for better
how Alfred looked at Bruce Wayne who was
kind of governed by this notion of
Vengeance and was kind of like you have
to become better and and Bruce Wayne
finally kind of buys into it and says
yes you know with the entire city with
with me being the only thing that I have
left yes I ask you for a signal what do
I do and he kind of gets one in the form
of like an electric storm and he says I
will become a better Batman right now we
don't know what this means that's what
this is so that's what makes this so
cool we don't know if Bruce is like yes
I'm going to become a better Batman I'm
going to be more ruthless I'm going to
be more cruel I'm going to be more I'm
going to be like I was after Jason Todd
died basically until like Tim Drake
showed up into my life and became the
new Robin or if he's like I'm going to
be a more honorable Batman right I'm
going to make up for the failings that I
had when I initially became the guy that
I became is it going to be a Batman who
works alongside all the other villains
to take out the Joker we have no IDE
idea we got to wa to the next issue
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
was going to pick up with uh Batman
Joker War the newest installment of the
Joker War but we're going to Sidetrack
from that for a second we're going to
cover the origin of punchline so I feel
like this is probably one of the more
interesting stories right and kind of
what I think a lot of Batman fans want
to know right like what's the story of
punchline how did punchline become the
Joker's new girlfriend right so this
comes out of the Joker 80th anniversary
uh 100 page super Spectacular One Shot
and and comic books do this for those of
you guys who are new Comics do this from
time to time right they'll have like a
super popular character that's been
around for a really really long time and
they'll do like a one-hot comic to
celebrate that character like when
Action Comics reach issue number 1,000
they did like a whole bunch of different
stories just celebrating the history of
Superman and it was just like this this
great big huge amalgamation of different
stories from different writers and
different artists and different things
like that it was cool it was it was
pretty awesome and this one's more or
less the same way but what this does
here and this is actually a cool little
tribute it picks up in a place called
Snider College of course named for Scott
Snider because aside from Dennis O'Neal
and Neil Adams he's probably the single
most influential Batman writer in the
history of the character to be honest
with you guys you know like it's it's
kind of nuts given like the work he did
the fact that like when new 52 launched
that it brought in a whole new wave of
Batman readers and the story was written
so well and it's probably one of the
most celebrated Batman stories of all
time right one of the most celebrated
Batman runs that's ever been written so
it makes sense right that they would
just be kind of a tribute here plus I'm
pretty sure James Kenyan and Scott
Snyder are friends so this picks up
basically with with what's more or less
just called kind of a a make your you
know celebrate your superhero day is
really what this is and you've got this
guy Dean Bob who's talking to this young
woman right this girl named Alexis and
the reason why is because of the fact
that in in really within the last little
while there was an attack in Gotham City
where a girl named Sarah had lost you
know some some people that she knew and
this was all you know as a result of a
of a joker attack right a gas attack and
the reason why this matters is because
unlike everybody else who's basically
celebrating their favorite Heroes you
know celebrating you know the flash or
Batman or Green Lantern or Superman or
something like that Alexis has a joker
shirt on you know she's celebrating the
Joker which is wildly provocative right
and it's not simply just her wearing a
shirt like she's kind of obsessed with
the character of The Joker right she's
obsessed with everything about him right
she's got posters she's got like all
kinds of stuff drawings artistic
renderings the funny thing about this is
that some of these drawings are are a
combination of things right so you've
got uh an Alex Ross depiction of the
Joker which is up there uh you've got
the Joker from the killing joke you've
got like just different versions of his
character over the years uh that are
shown that this this is this doesn't
necessarily mean that it's like an incon
thing just kind of a cool little tribute
by the artist of the comic right is
really all it is but the idea is that
the dean comes down here tell you know
telling her hey like this is kind of a
problem you have to take this this whole
you got to take this shirt off right
this is kind of offensive to people and
the reality is that where he he claims
that he came down here as a friend she
kind of calls it right off the bat and
it's like no you didn't come down here
as a friend you came down here because
you're scared of this shirt you're
scared of what it represents and you
know that it's dangerous right what you
want me to do is to go out into the quad
right kind of usually on universities
you have what's called a quad which is
like a great big huge Park area more or
less inside the in inside the University
where most people hang out at and she's
like you want me to go down there and
you want me to like let out some some
tear-jerking cry about how I'm
maladjusted and this shirt is just some
outward manifestation of the inner
turmoil that I'm struggling with because
I really can't figure my place out and
I'm just crying out for help and all
that kind of stuff and she's like no
that's not the case at all that's not
what this is It's not that I'm
maladjusted it's not that I'm I'm crying
out for help that's not at all what's
going on here your concern here is that
you have a danger a dangerous student
who believes in something dangerous
that's operating right under your nose
and in the midst of all all that she
literally like blows smoke in his face
and when that happens of course he you
know kind of waves it out of the way and
then kind of starts talking to her and
as he's talking to her begins to kind of
start laughing a little bit right and
he's like what in the world did you do
to me and she's like well I got the
recipe off the internet and I didn't
know if it really works I didn't know if
it was going to work at all you wouldn't
believe how many different chemicals it
that it takes in order to make it but I
have a pretty good teacher right looking
at the closet you know she's like I have
a pretty good teacher so it's like okay
got a laptop stored in there or
something like that but you know she's
like for for me like the paralytic is
finally sitting in but don't fight any
of it right I want to get all of this on
camera and the reason why is because
that girl Sarah has been playing up her
whole tragedy for likes right she's been
playing it all up on social media she's
trying to get the world to feel bad for
her you know and how crappy of a person
do you have to be to take your own
personal tragedy and throw it out there
on the internet not because of the fact
that you actually care about the people
who who had bad things done to them not
because you care about them as people
but because you know that sympathy story
is going to get you more likes it's
going to get you more followers right
you're doing it just to manipulate
people how crappy of a person do you
have to be in order to pull that off but
if what she wants is horror then I will
bring her horror if what she wants is
suffering then I will bring her
suffering if what she wants is real pain
that she can put on the internet then
that's what I will give her I'm going to
dress you up like a victim of the Joker
and I'm going to put you in her bed and
so that when she comes in she's not
going to be posting on social media for
likes she's going to experience
nightmares day after day after day she's
going to see your face in her sleep and
she'll never catch A Moment's Peace I
will give her what it is that she wants
I'll give her what it is that she's
asking for even if she doesn't know that
she's asking asking for it right and
that's what's kind of crazy here because
this girl like Alexis she's just dark
and that's kind of what she says she's
like this is all your fault you asked
for this right you and your generation
asked for this you grew you you kept
telling us as we could grow up we could
be anything we wanted to and you left us
some kind of half-ass world to living we
could be anything we wanted to what you
never considered is that some of us
don't want to be the good guys we don't
want to be the ones who save the world
we want to be the ones who destroy it we
want to be the ones who tear it down and
build it into something better and
something new now that's that's actually
an amazing point to make right because
there's certain assumptions that are
made right I kind of Sidetrack this for
you know for a second there's certain
assumptions that are made right and it's
kind of like these Unwritten assumptions
right like when we tell our kids you can
be anything you want we tell them that
under the assumption that what they want
to be is something good right like a
contributing member of society and
that's not an unreasonable assumption to
make nobody says you know hey like you
know I told my child they could be
anything and so they became like a
sociopath like that's not really you
know what what what we aspire to what we
aspire to is I told my child I you know
they could be anything and so they
became Batman that's what we're talking
about right just like awesome things in
the real world I would right like that's
that's like that Meme right they said I
could be anything so I became I became
Batman like that's that's it's it's cool
right it's a it's a cool little thing
it's it's it's nice and so because of
that you know this is kind of the
opposite side it's people basically
getting what they asked for just not
exactly what they were asking for right
like she was raised and Tall you could
be anything you want to but the other
part of this is there's kind of a darker
side to this the way she sees the world
is a darker place right the world sucks
the world's crappy the world's full of
terrible people right if Humanity wanted
to get it together Humanity would have
gotten it together by now but Humanity
hasn't right and so humanity is
inherently bad people just don't care
about other people regardless of what
they say right they say one thing they
do another and so because of that like
it's important to just rip it all down
and that's where she became enamored
with the joker right like the whole
world is built on this ridiculous joke
and she's the punchline right hence
where she got her name from and that's
when he kind of starts basically
succumbing to the Joker toxin or at
least this basic toxin in the most
intense way and then from there she kind
of chimes in and she says okay like like
speaking to a person we can't see if
what you wanted was for me to prove that
I'm not some fan girl right if what you
wanted was for me to prove that I'm
actually serious about wanting to become
your henchmen then here's the proof
here's the proof that I'm ready to get
serious and we find out that in that
closet is the Joker himself right by
some Manner and some means she managed
to get a hold of the Joker but she
managed to get a hold of this guy and
this guy was intrigued by her he was
interested in her now we all kind of
know that at the end of the day she's a
means to an end right that's really all
punchline is she's just a way for Jer to
like achieve a goal or to get back at
Batman or even to get back at Harley
Quinn right the Joker's schemes don't
make sense to anybody but himself but
regardless of what his motivations are
she got his attention and she was
interesting enough that he didn't kill
her so because of that you know she's
kind of like you know what what comes
next is going to be wild right like it's
it's going to be it's it's it's going to
be insane it's going to be serious and
the Joker's response is no it's not
going to be serious my dear punchline
what comes next is going to be hilarious
right and so what this does is it
basically kind of bookends to everything
that starts with the Batman story with
the joker War right well really even
before that introduction of punchline
and all that kind of stuff so in terms
of our Batman playlist we'll probably
position it up there uh you know
basically ahead of everything else so
you can kind of go into it knowing who
punchline is and having that whole story
uh you'll kind of have to ignore the
segments that we that we were talking
about in the previous videos where we're
like we don't know anything about
punchline so maybe I'll just leave it
here I don't know I'll figure it
out all right what's going on guys this
is Rob and we are picking up with the
official event of Joker war and I love
this story like this is amazing here's
the other thing too it's good to see
Jorge here's the thing I'm not sure
exactly how it's pronounced is it Jorge
gimz or is it Jorge uh Jimenez I'm not
100% sure how to pronounce it because I
know that the J is silent in Spanish but
I think it's only silent under certain
circumstances so I'm not sure but
nonetheless uh we are picking up with
with the very beginning of Joker war and
this is the cool thing because what this
does is it actually picks up years ago
right at some point presumably in the
early days of Batman's career and
there's a couple reasons why we can kind
of pit this together and I'll talk about
that here in a second but what's
happened here is the various experiences
of Batman and dealing with the joker are
starting to come to a head in the sense
that all these individuals who are
killed through the Joker toxin are
deformed in some pretty gruesome ways
now the crazy thing about this is you
don't really see people like that in
recent in recent days right in recent
years with the use of Joker toxin right
they just kind of seem to die with a
smile on their face but with these
really gruesome expressions and gruesome
appearances it's messed up but it's kind
of cool to see at the same time right
that to kind of show the heinousness and
the callousness of the Joker reflected
in how people look when they perish at
the hands of the Joker toxin it's kind
of wild but one of the things that's
going on here of course Alfred being
alive but Batman talking to him and
Alfred kind of asked the question how
many has this quote unquote Joker figure
already killed and Batman kind of
responds by I'm not really sure this is
going to end and that kind of a thing so
the discussion they're having is that
they don't really fully understand who
this Joker guy is or what he's about and
this all really points at the idea that
they've just encountered The Joker
seemingly for the very first time or in
the very early days now the reason why
this matters is because we go back to
Batman zero year and we go back to the
origin of the Joker at least in so far
as we got during the New 52 and we have
this idea of when Batman first
encountered Joker that happened in the
very very early days of him becoming a
superhero right so we're talking about
within like the first two to three years
of Bruce Wayne becoming Batman when when
this took place this is very very early
on but one of the things that Bruce
Wayne picks up on pretty easily is that
the Joker's motivations as he said in
Batman the Animated Series his schemes
make sense to no one but himself and
that's what makes the Joker so dangerous
one of the things that Batman kind of
picks up on here is that when it comes
to the average criminal they do what
they do because of money or because of
the thrill right whatever the case is
like they do it as a contract killing
right so it's it's like when Agnes heler
outlined the three reasons why people
commit crimes right people commit crimes
for profit in which case the
consequences don't matter people commit
crimes out of passion right like some
guy or some girl comes home and finds
their significant other cheating on them
they lose their minds and stab them to
death or they do it out of compulsion
they couldn't help themselves but
regardless of the situation neither of
these three things matter to the
consequences the third one seems to be
what what applies to the Joker that for
whatever reason he sees the whole world
is basically meat in the eyes of the
Joker everybody's already dead all he's
doing is just kind of helping them along
the way and then achieving his own goal
in the process but it's this really
almost wholesome moment right when he's
talking to Alfred and Alfred is like
there's no way I'd let you face off
against a guy like this on your own for
the rest of your life right and so what
this does is it allows basically Batman
to kind of break or at least you know
the Batmobile to break into an aqueduct
for all that kind of stuff to go nuts
right Bruce Wayne driving his Batmobile
but more so than that we get these sort
of news flips right Wayne Enterprises is
experiencing what's basically a hostile
takeover in the sense that joker has
taken over all the assets of Wayne
Enterprises right that Bruce Wayne
himself has basically indicated a kind
of pattern of embezzlement siphoning
money off of Wayne Enterprises illegally
and then using it for personal means
that Harland Graves you guys know him as
the underr from the the last few stories
that we did he's the guy who's basically
the legal counsel for Wayne Enterprises
now and the other part of this is that
the the Gotham Gazette received a
multi-billion dollar cease and assists
right so they were basically told if you
don't stop publishing these articles
saying the Joker's the one who took over
Wayne Enterprises we're going to sue you
guys into Oblivion which of course the
news ended up giving away because you
know 2020 that's what the news does but
nonetheless you know it's one of these
things where the where basically from
all different directions Wayne
Enterprises in its entirety is now
completely and totally under control of
the Joker and his henchmen right Batman
is not only does he does he not have any
control of his company he's wanted for
embezzlement and so this guy's back is
against the wall in almost every
conceivable way the other part of this
is that when it comes to Lucius Fox he's
basically being he's basically infected
with the joker talk box not in the most
extreme degree but just enough to where
uh the punchline can get the kind of
information that she needs out of him so
she can relay it to the Joker and what
she wants to know are all the different
locations that Batman has within the
city of Gotham but more specifically
within you know Wayne Enterprises that
he can use at any particular point in
time now again this is a great way for
James tinon to actually feed off of what
we've seen over the years from Scott
Snider's New 52 run this is one of the
things that SNY brought in where in the
various buildings that were built by
Wayne Enterprises or purchased by Wayne
Enterprises that Batman had put in these
little you know kind of mini bat caves
that he could operate out of in almost
any situation right so no matter what
the emergency is he can go there and he
can operate out of that place and so
where where Lucius Fox kind of asked the
question where's the Joker gone to
punchline says where would you go if you
suddenly became worth $100 billion and
so we pick up with the Monarch Theater
now the Monarch Theater for those of you
guys who don't know is a is a
significant place in the history of the
Batman Mythos and the reason why is
because this is the theater that Bruce
Wayne and his parents were at when they
left and they were shot to death in
Crime Alley and so you end up having the
owner of the theater who's just kind of
taking the The Joker on a tour through
this place right kind of showing Joker
around and he's almost kind of
explaining to the Joker what's going on
right that this place used to be part of
what was called Crime Alley this is
where the wayes were killed that you
couldn't really walk up and down the
street without having to worry about you
know being being shot or something like
that which really sort of sort of begs a
question why in the world did the Wade
family go to the seediest part of town
to see a movie theater right was there
just like not a theater close to them
right that they could have gone to
because let me tell you something guys
in in every town there's two theaters
right the theaters that rich people go
to and the movie theaters rich people
used to go to those are the two kinds of
theaters that exist I remember that was
an old Chris Rock routine from back in
the day but it's true right the rich
kind of have a tendency to cut
themselves off from anybody who's deemed
to be not rich so I guess maybe it does
say something about the Wayne family
that they spent time at uh at the
Monarch Theater but regardless it's an
explanation here by this guy and and
basically saying this place has a has a
a pretty rough history about it right
like there's almost a kind of spirit of
of Vengeance almost a kind of spirit of
Haunting that that permeates throughout
this place where it's just sadness and
misery all this time because following
the death of the waines and and really
kind of the collapse of this part of
Gotham nobody really goes there anymore
and it's kind of a crazy thing because
even Wayne you know Bruce Wayne had
shown up here a couple times and tried
to buy this place and was always turned
down every single time and so where this
you know owner basically says that he
kind of hears what sounds like laughter
the response of the Joker is well it's
probably just the wind right you know
old theaters like this they probably
have that kind of wind going through
here and so what we end up learning is
that the Joker approached this own with
a massive amount of money now we're not
given an actual numerical value but we
can kind of specify that it's enough to
buy a small town right you know so it
was it's probably in the millions if not
possibly in the the you know double
digit Millions it's an exceedingly high
amount of money and so what ends up
happening is this guy continually kind
of picks up on the fact that there's
some kind of laughter here and the Joker
says you know what you should go join
them in the audience the show is getting
ready to start and this guy doesn't know
what the Joker's talking about of course
the Joker's watching The Mark of Zoro
which is the movie that Bruce Wayne and
his family were watching when they left
the theater and they were killed but
basically we end up finding out that all
these individuals out there who were
jokerized are sitting down in the
audience and of course this Usher this
movie owner is going to go the same way
right he's going to get jokerized too
and that's basically going to be the end
of him but again it's it's kind of nuts
because you have this scenario where
Bruce Wayne finally makes his way into
the Wayne Enterprises building and when
that happens he kind of just starts
looking around right analyzing where the
various people are all the henchmen with
guns and it's the smartest move of the
Joker to put in as many people here as
possible Right to station everybody on
every conceivable floor not only that
because Batman basically gains access
directly into one of the mini bat caves
one of the micro caves he almost kind of
assumes it's a safe haven but as soon as
the lights come on you've got punchline
there who immediately goes after him now
here's the important thing to understand
punchline has no chance against Batman
right so before people start comenting
no way punchline would win yeah we know
like we know punchline wouldn't win
against Batman right at that point
you're just preaching to the
audience you're just stating the obvious
right like the sky is
blue that's all it really comes down to
but it's it's kind of a funny thing and
this is what I love about how James
Tenon handles this because you've got
punchline on one side you've got Bruce
Wayne on the other under any normal
circumstance when I say normal I mean
punch line being herself and the only
way she could win is she had the powers
of Superman she still comes out on top
and the reason why is because you have
this moment where she goes and attacks
Bruce and Bruce basically kind of
implements these small little things
here and there these small little
devices but punchline knows about all
these right the booby traps and things
that are there this kind of iconic
Batman suit that's there right like this
holy new Batman suit that I've never
seen before but looks amazing like it
looks so cool it's almost kind of like a
John Henry iron steel Batman suit you
know like like Superman suit but for
Batman it's almost kind of what it looks
like right like okay here's what I want
to know everybody watching this video If
You Could name this Batman suit what
would you nameing you know that's what
we're going to call this video the new
Batman suit like if you could name this
suit what would you call it that's what
I want to know cuz it looks cool but the
other thing and this is why this is why
I love the way tenyon handles this is
that again like it's punchline in a room
Batman in a room punch Line's going to
lose but then we end up finding out that
what she'd been doing here is Batman
starts to kind of get a little hazy
right get a little foggy in the brain a
little sluggish and punchline basically
tells him oh what's actually going on
here is that I have I've been permeating
this room with poison this entire time
it's one part Joker toxin it's one point
fear Toxin and one point Venom and the
Venom you know the Venom basically
prevents The Joker toxin from killing
you but it basically enhances what goes
on with the fear toxin right so it's
kind of like this wicked cocktail and
this is genius man like it's so cool
because the initial knee-jerk reaction
to this would be like no way Batman
would go into this but here's the other
thing you have to you have to understand
Batman wouldn't expect anybody to know
that he has these little micro caves
they're probably not even on the
blueprints right the only person who
would know about it is Lucius Fox and
the expectation is that Lucius Fox isn't
hiding nobody would really be able to
get to him in the conventional way and
so it's cool right because it's just a
way to kind of get the upper hand on
Batman the thing is like once he starts
making his way or at least he tries to
leave suddenly he's met by the voice of
Alfred saying like hey you're going the
wrong way you're going backwards and
when Batman's kind of like Alfred what
in the heck is going on then like Alfred
chimes in and says like he's taking
everything right he's taking the
vehicles he's taking your city he's
taking everything you have to get out of
there and Batman looks up and realizes
the Batwing is flying towards him right
this jokerized batwing is flying towards
him and it's just and Batman's like what
in the world like you're you're supposed
to be dead right and Alfred's response
is I'm sorry my boy I'm so sorry we're
all dead now and that happens right is
this thing open fires directly on Bruce
Wayne right so like the Batwing looks
like it kills Batman
okay so we are picking up with uh Batman
the Joker War part two part do and
here's here's a funny thing man like I
feel like James tenon's killing it on
Batman which my bigger question is why
didn't they slap him on Batman
before okay so the cool thing about this
is that this initially picks up in
Gotham City right and we're just kind of
giv this idea that it's years from now
right some point in the future but
basically like you have what amounts to
almost kind of like this futur
futuristic version of Gotham right I
mean it's it's it's almost like a Utopia
like what Metropolis is right it's sunny
and it's beautiful and it's not crappy
and thunderstorm the way it is now so
basically like it's not Seattle but
basically like you've got Batman chasing
down the freeze family now it's kind of
weird one because of the fact that every
time I see the name Victor freeze I
always think of Victor Fries and two
because he's got kids right one of them
is called like snow cone and it's like
and the other one's like ice pop it's
like all right James T we got to work on
your name scheme a lot of this kind of
seems to be individuals or young kids
who were just kind of wrapped up in
Victor free and taken to be as you know
more or less like proteges I mean as far
as I'm aware Nora doesn't have the
ability to produce children unless he
made them using you know her DNA or
something like that but regardless
Batman takes them out pretty quickly and
then we switch back to the bad cave
right like the kids are basically being
shunted off so they can receive some
kind of treatment and Bruce Wayne's an
older guy and it's kind of wild to see
him that way because my initial thought
was okay so like Superman became Batman
basically which is kind of a kind of a
weird theme but he's called Master Bruce
so it's it's Bruce Wayne and it's kind
of nuts right because we're given this
idea that like Gotham is everything
Batman wanted it to be that it's this
beautiful utopian place where crime is a
is an almost non-existent concept you do
have a few criminals who pop up every
now and then but instead of Gotham being
this terrible cess poool of a place
where all the worst possible things
could and do happen then instead it's
any city everywhere that has some
measure of crime right for the most most
part it's a great place just a few bad
apples the problem with this is that
it's all an illusion because immediately
Alfred just kind of starts losing his
mind his next snaps he's got the Joker
grin and he's like this whole thing is
lies you're going to die alone with no
family with no one to love you you're
going to die a lonely miserable life
right like Batman's biggest fears and
then he snaps up right snap back to
reality as Eminem once said like he
snaps right back up and he's basically
just kind of recovering from this toxin
that he was hit with by punchline now
that's kind of the crazy thing because
the toxin that she used is wildly potent
and that's what makes it so wild I
wouldn't go as far as to say Batman has
like an inherent you know immunity to
like the fear toxin of the Scarecrow but
it's something that he's used to and to
have it impact him in this way where
he's been out for days is kind of nuts
right it's kind of wild now of course
Harley Quinn was the one who saved him
you know Harley Quinn looking the way
she is she was she's the one who saved
him and of course she you know more or
less had herself stitched up you know
from her injuries but with the three
days that he's been out Batman kind of
asks what's going on Gotham has
descended into absolute Madness and I
absolutely adore the way this has been
done by James tenyon right because my
fear I'll be honest with you guys my
legitimate fear going into this when
tinan was like well here comes Joker
taking over Gotham it was going to be a
repeat of endgame right where he just
like floods the with Joker talk and
everybody goes crazy I was afraid that's
what was going to happen no not at all
instead Joker's there but it's really
kind of punchline who's running the show
and for the most part the various gangs
of Gotham have all unified under the
ideology of the Joker right so they're
all basically Joker gangs they've
basically taken Batmobiles turn them
into Joker mobiles Joker Cycles Joker
planes a whole nine yards like all of
Batman's gadgets and and and uses have
been handed over to the to the Joker
crowd the other part of this is that
people are basically just kind of
fleeing for their lives as best they can
the whole City's turned into madness but
you do have a few instances of people
who have taken up arms themselves it's
kind of a cool thing to see right the
people have basically just taken up arms
to protect their city as best they can
and ultimately that's what it runs into
in this kind of situation that it's only
when things are at their absolute worst
that people will actually get up and
stand up for themselves right that if
they have somebody there to protect them
to keep them safe they'll rely on them
almost all the time but for the most
part like any scenario we would expect
the city's Madness you basically have
people who are are running a muck under
the mantle of the jok versus what few
people here and there are trying to do
what they can to keep themselves safe
while almost everybody else is just
hiding in fear and that's why you know
Batman kind of asks like where's the
Joker in all of this and that's where
Harley responds The Joker is not really
the one running the show all the time a
punchline is the one running most of the
show that's going on the under broker
basically has his lawyers keeping the
city at Bay right so in a lot of ways
it's kind of The Dark Knight Returns
right instead of it being Bane that
cripples the city of Gotham it's the
Joker who's done it by taking all of his
resources and all that kind of stuff now
I know there are huge parallels there
but to be honest with you guys just
based on what we've seen with Gotham
being the way that it is I actually kind
of think this is better and so from
there Harley ends up revealing that the
Joker kind of has like this you know
Joker bought up ad time basically in in
the city of Gotham because we know you
know with with news companies and so on
if the money's there they don't care and
so what you end up having is basically
just like the Joker running ads all the
time on TV with the same kind of thing
right the guy that you thought died
right the the old man who ran the
theater who apparently didn't know who
the Joker was which is kind of weird a z
was carved onto his face which is pretty
gruesome and he tells like this amazing
I mean it's it's not funny but it is a
thrilling tale of Adventure romance and
Vengeance a story of a man reborn as a
hero a story of the symbol he would use
to Mark the world the mark of Zoro
remastered and better than ever this is
the Gotham
cut only three people saw the ending
last time and it changed the course of
the city's history what happens when
everybody sees the real ending the mark
of Zoro now playing back-to-back soldout
screenings at the Monarch Theater wide
release is only days away coming to
every movie house in Gotham City and
like as he reads this off it's like
prepare for the final shot he's like no
please like the Joker shoots him it's
not funny but it
[Music]
is this is why I love the Joker man of
course this this brings back terrible
memories for Batman right like Monarch
Theater and Harley grabs him and kind of
snaps him out of it right and it's kind
of cool to see that like Harley Quinn's
the one who's trying to pull Batman back
from the edge like you would think it'd
be Selena Kyle in this instance but at
the moment it's Harley right Selena Kyle
bailed out right it's Harley who's
trying to pull him back and it's
interesting to see because you don't
really see her in that light the closest
I think I ever really saw to Harley
Quinn in this way was during the New 52
Batman run by Scott Snider when she
approached Batman and told him like
Joker's not who he used to be now of
course that was after she hit him with a
sledgehammer knocked him into a vat
while she was wearing a red hood mask
you know she's like you know Joker's not
the same that he used to be he's not the
same old Mr J like he's he's different
now there's something different and
twisted about him now that wasn't the
same way it was before I feel like
that's the closest we got but one of the
things she says here and this is what's
so cool she's like you can't go go out
there right now and do all this you're
not in the mindset to do it you still
got this toxin running through your
veins you still got to let it work out
of your system if you go out there now
and you get yourself killed then like
we're all going to die right so it's
interesting to see Harley Quinn in this
position to where she's like beseeching
Batman to stay behind because he's the
only one that can really keep them alive
but the cool thing about this is Batman
finds a method of control and that's
what I think makes the fear toxin so
incredibly potent right because when
you're infected with this toxin your
imagination becomes your enemy but for
Batman he's a wildly focused to
individual and what he does is focus all
of this into the voice of Alfred and so
it's kind of like Alfred comes back in
this regard that Batman knows Alfred
isn't there and he knows he's not real
but letting the fear toxin take the form
of Alfred's voice is one kind of
focusing this fear toxin in a way where
it's not nearly as potent and two
putting it to use because he becomes
Batman's conscience and that's kind of
what Alfred was right he was the voice
in the back of Batman's head that was
guiding him when he wasn't always there
letting him know what the right thing to
do is and so of course with everything
kind of going down you know people being
corn cored by these these you know gangs
and so on and so forth Batman basically
leaps in takes a few of them out and
then kind of goes goes about right I
mean Batman's not the kind of guy where
he would like look at these people being
attacked by The Joker gangs and be like
best of luck here's a batarang you got
it and then just and just take off
Batman's going to fight those guys off
and then you know continue on his way to
the to the Monarch Theater but as he
gets in there it's a horrifying
experience for Batman for a variety of
reasons right one because the mark of
Zoro is most of you guys know was the
movie as family went to go see when you
know of course they were shot and
Monarch Theater was the theater they
were coming out of so this is like a a
terrifying experience for Bruce Wayne
now at this point in his life you he's
basically passed it you know his
parents' death is really more of a means
to achieve a particular goal as opposed
to the thing that that kind of haunts
him and keeps him down and so what he
ends up doing is once he gets in there
the whole place smells like death right
Rotting Flesh the whole nine yards
everybody in here is basically dead and
it's a wild scenario because Joker pops
up and he's kind of like when Batman
asked the question like why are all
these corpses here like they look like
they've been decaying for years the
response of of Joker is because they
have right this is our family this is
every one that I've killed in the
pursuit in this cat and mouse game that
you and I have going on everyone who's
been a victim of mine and what I've done
is I've given them a kind of toxin I've
given them a substance that will
reanimate them in effect Joker creates
his own zombies and sends them all after
Batman what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are back again with the events of
Joker War this time we're on part three
and if I'm being honest with you guys I
think we are getting what is more or
less a new Red Hood and I'll explain
what I mean here in a minute because
there's Red Hood as you guys know him
and then there's Jason Todd the way he
originally was which I feel like only
the most DieHard fans would probably
know but this initially picks up in Tri
Corner yards right basically the
shipyards in Gotham City and we
basically got punchline now again this
is one of the things that I love that
James hyon's doing with punchline with
Harley Quinn this is something that's
kind of interesting with Harley Quinn
she was the sidekick of the Joker but
more in so far as she was like the comic
relief as well as the one that was
designed to kind of maintain the sex
appeal with punchline sure she's
somewhat drawn in that way way but she's
a lot more Hands-On in terms of like the
Joker's ongoing operations making sure
things run like she's like a field
commander more or less it's kind of what
you would expect but I do really like
the nature of punch line one of the big
things that kind of goes into this
though is that with all these containers
being moved this is all part of the
Joker toxin right that the Joker
basically plans to use on the city of
Gotham the problem with this is that the
henchmen of the Joker are a little
uncertain about going into to what's
basically the Narrows right like the the
Shady part of town and you wouldn't
really expect that of the Joker henchmen
they're literally criminals and thugs
right like if anybody was going to be at
home in the narrows it would be these
guys but there's something in the narrow
that scares the crap out of them and
what we end up doing is picking up with
the with the narrow the day before right
in this this neighborhood and we pick up
with clown Hunter now this is kind of
the cool thing this is why I say this
guy I think is kind of like the new
Jason Todd right like the new red hood
so what you end up having was a couple
of the henchmen of the Joker who were
basically driving the Batmobile or at
least one version of the Batmobile and
clown Hunter ended up tracking them down
and then basically you know
incapacitated the vehicle using like a
fire hydrant right because it's like
electrically powered and so on so this
guy basically figures out a way to Short
Circuit the Batmobile which if I'm being
honest with you guys kind of on the
fence about right I feel like if Batman
were going to create a vehicle designed
to basically allow him to fight crime in
the city of Gotham one of the first
things he would think of is what happens
if it gets wet what happens if it's
raining outside but that's kind of the
cool thing right this kid's Ingenuity
because it wasn't simply just water that
led to this thing being being you know
being short circuited it was him bring
like a portable Transformer and that's
all it really took right just like an
electrical base some water and then like
a huge surge of electricity and so with
this thing being uh being incapacitated
he ends up cracking one of the windows
and then pours gasoline inside and sets
it on fire and the guys burn alive the
reason why I say I feel like this guy is
the is the new red hood is because when
it comes to Jason Todd there's two
versions of his character there's Jason
Todd as he was originally created then
there's Jason Todd the character who he
became after the events of crisis on
infinite Earth so in the original
appearances of Jason Todd well you
didn't necessarily see him do anything
as hardcore as this there was an
instance where he actually pushed a
criminal off a ledge now by the time
Batman got up there the criminal had
fallen and the response to Jason Todd
was well you know I mean he fell there
was nothing I could do but it was
heavily alluded to that Jason pushed him
over right like Jason was the reason
that guy died and it was kind of given
to us that Jason was not Dick Grayson
right Dick Grayson was the guy like he
was a Believer right like he believed in
the cause of Batman and he he fought
alongside Batman you know until he
decided to go on and become Nightwing
that kind of a thing but he never would
have gone down that darker path Jason
Todd did and that was something the fans
didn't like my fans didn't like the idea
of Jason Todd becoming more extreme more
intense combined with the fact that his
origin was basically identical to Dick
Grayson's right they saw him as like a
darker car carbon copy of Dick Grayson
himself and so that's why you went into
the post crisis landscape DC changed his
origin fans still hated him so they got
him they they basically killed him off
but Jason Todd was very very dark in his
early appearances in in DC Comics right
and that's what this feels like right
this feels like Jason Todd the way he
originally was and and that's why I say
I think I think this is important
because I have a hard time believing
that some character named clown Hunter
that's given a name by James tenant
established in terms of who this guy is
and he's tracking down the various
villains of the Joker that he's killing
them off everywhere that he can find
them I have a hard time believing this
kid's just going to kind of be thrown
away what I think is going to happen is
that at the end of all this he's going
to be taken under Batman's wing and he's
going to become the new Robin maybe
maybe not the new Robin per se maybe
just kind of like a different name but
it's going to lead to like Damen Wayne
probably you know continuing to be Robin
but doing his thing on the Teen Titans
and this guy becoming the new sidekick
of Batman right I'm not really sure how
that'll go down but that's kind of what
it feels like but what it leads to is it
leads to punchline basically saying okay
fine if this is the case I'll go and
track this person down myself or get a
hold of the Joker or whatever but like
your job is to get this to his
destination if you have to go around the
Narrows then go around the Narrows but
if it's not where it needs to be in time
then you guys are going to be the ones
I'm going to point the finger to and do
you really want the Joker coming after
you because you missed your shipment
make your choice but make sure you
Choose Wisely now the other part of this
is it switches over to Batman dealing
with this movie theater full of all
these corpses and the Joker hits in and
this is something that I love the most
so this is why I love what James Tiny's
doing with Batman you end up having the
Joker talking to Bruce Wayne right you
know he's kind of been taunting him
giving him a bit of a hard time while
Batman's dealing with all this and he
says you know I wonder which one of
these of these people hate you more
right because like these are all corpses
of people who have died at my hands I
wonder which ones hate you more the ones
who basically died at the very beginning
of all this when you underestimated how
many people would die in all of our
conflicts or the ones who died recently
knowing the longer I was out there the
more people I would kill and that's the
coolest line of logic because that's one
of the things that I've always kind of
said about Batman that while people will
say well Batman doesn't kill right
that's the rule of Batman the question
becomes like is it a good rule to have
right just because it's a rule doesn't
mean that it's a good Rule and when
you're talking about so many bystanders
being killed on a regular basis then
what it does is it allows you to shine
Batman in different lights right you can
you can shine Batman in a more positive
light and say see he's a good hero he
doesn't kill but then you can shine him
in what's really a more realistic light
and say yeah but as villains do and for
every villain that he lead that that
basically gets out onto the streets and
Batman believes in this Rehabilitation
tactic and then in turn gets these
villains back into Arkham Asylum knowing
they're probably going to escape where
they're going to get back out they're
probably going to end up killing some
people then it turns into is Batman
really doing Gotham any good because if
he knows the villains are going to
escape but he won't kill them and he
knows the villains are going to kill
people Batman is in effect sacrificing
innocent lives for his belief that he
can rehabilitate you know villains like
the Joker that's basically what it is
right the rehabilitation of the Joker is
more important than the life of the
average person we know that by virtue of
Batman's actions and that's that's
that's what makes this discussion and
this debate so cool is Batman really a
good hero can you really call yourself a
good hero if you willingly and knowingly
sacrifice the lives of innocent people
in order to try to fix a villain there
has to come a time when you basically
say okay enough is enough I'm not
willing to sacrifice any more innocent
lives for you like I will break my code
for this like sure it'll make me as bad
as you but the city will be better for
it it's an amazing little little
philosophy here that the Joker has kind
of pointing at that fallacy of Batman
right like look at all these innocent
people that I've killed and think of all
the innoc the other innocent people that
I'm going to kill because I'm going to
make all of them relive your experience
I'm literally paying them to come to
this theater and they're going to watch
the mask of Zoro and they're going to
have the time of their life and then I'm
going to start pumping my Joker toxin in
here and they're going to die and
they're going to be reanimated with
these nanites is one of my henchmen
right so they have no idea it's coming
but we're going to do this over and over
and over and over again it's awesome I
think that that the way the Joker is
being handled here is amazing because I
think one of the biggest problems the
Joker has over the years in DC Comics is
the Joker's only ever really shown in in
one of like two or three different ways
you're either given the super silly
Joker from like Steve inglehart you get
like the silly and the sadistic Joker
which is what you got back in like the
40s with Bob Kane and Bill Finger when
he first popped up or you get like the
Scott Snider New 52 just crazy Twisted
Joker but to have this version here
who's kind of like a combination of all
of them right like he's he's he's silly
he's Twisted but he's also incredibly
dark makes this some of the best Joker
storytelling that I've read in a long
long time and that's my question which
version of the Joker do you guys like
more do you like the one from like the
new 52 Batman run or do you like this
version because I'll be honest with you
guys I kind of like this version more
right like I love the way it's drawn and
I love the way he acts and I love his
plan I really dig that now the other
thing here is remember while Batman is
hallucinating because of this toxin he
has feeding on it right so Alfred's been
dead Alfred's been dead since the events
uh since he was killed during city of
Bane during Tom King's Batman run and so
Batman you know basically hallucinating
Alfred is a way for him to essentially
control this hallucination hallucination
experience that he's having to control
all of that now where his mind and where
the Joker kind of starts getting into
his head and he actually starts to
hallucinate all these different people
who are coming after him as Jokers right
when in reality they're just you know
corpses essentially Batman's able to
basically issue an EMP that will take
out his earpiece so he won't really be
able to hear Alfred anymore quote
unquote and of course it'll take out the
nanites that are controlling all these
corpses and basically kind of have them
coming back right because they're not
truly reanimated Undead it's not like
Night of the Living Dead kind of stuff
going on here not really like a a
biological agent or anything along those
lines but once Batman makes his way out
of the theater and then collapses while
H hallucinating his parents he's rescued
by Harley Quinn again now this is where
the Joker gets cool is because what we
end up doing is jumping back to him
right we've got punchline showing up
here and basically saying hey there's
this kid out there in the Narrows that's
basically taking out our henchmen right
taking out our guys and where she thinks
the Joker is going to respond with like
being pissed off and throwing stuff
around instead like the Joker's excited
about it and when she asks why she's
like why would you be so happy about
this he's like because this is truly
chaos that we're finally seeing right
we're finally seeing chaos happening
that whenever you saw like Batgirl or or
for the most part in more recent years
the Red Hood and even the Red Hood was a
little sketchy but whenever you saw like
Damen Wayne you know like Robin or you
saw Tim Drake or you saw Dick Grayson
you saw some other member of the bat
family it was we don't kill right like
we'll beat you within an inch of your
life but we won't really go past that
inch you know we don't kill people it
was always the rule of gossam but now
we've got true chaos out here we've got
people who don't follow the rules of
Batman anymore you got people people out
there taking the Law into their own
hands because there's nobody else out
there to maintain law in order and so
it's like this is true chaos now like
this is this is what I was hoping for
this is what I was looking for and so
the response is like okay I mean do we
let this guy live and keep doing his
thing and the Joker is like of course
not kill him like crucify the guy so
people know that they can't do that but
it's just cool to
see this is one of the one of the funny
little Joker moments uh what what he end
up I'm telling like he kind of makes
this this comment to punchline like it's
time for me to finally basically off
Harley Quinn right to get rid of Harley
Quinn punchline loves that because now
she feels like she's actually the number
one in the Joker's life which As We Know
by virtue of Harley Quinn's experience H
it's not always the case but then you
have Batman who kind of wakes up in like
this crazy wonky looking Place who's
like licked by by a dog and he's like
Ace Ace is that you oh buddy buddy I've
missed you so much I haven't seen you in
so long Ace and it's like yeah it's me
Ace the bat hound and then it turns out
it's Harley
Quinn I loved that I love I I I saw that
I probably laughed for a solid 2 minutes
right like I thought that was hilarious
but anyway Batman basically wakes up and
Harley Quinn says this place is Eden and
this is a cool little expansion here she
really says that like within the city of
Gotham there's little secrets and little
hideouts little places that you don't
know about where us various villains get
together and we meet or we relax and
recuperate this is awesome you know up
and and and and I think this this is in
a lot of ways building on Snider's
Batman run and that's why the new 52
Batman run by Scott Snyder was just the
stuff of Legend because it did these
small little things where it introduced
elements whether they were huge or small
that changed the way that we saw Batman
because we always thought of Bruce Wayne
as like the Caped Crusader right the guy
who knows knows Gotham like the back of
his hand and then you get in a new 52
and it's like there's this criminal
Enterprise that's been operating in the
city of Gotham for hundreds of years and
Batman never knew about it and then you
go here into James tinan and it's like
there's these small little nooks and
crannies that Batman doesn't know about
it shows how ingenuitive the criminals
are like it shows how intelligent they
are and like finding places like they
know Batman's haunts so they know which
places to go to and they know which
places to avoid and it's cool to have
that right because apparently poison ivy
put all this together and initially it
was made for Harley Quinn when seemingly
she left Joker at one period in time and
was struggling with their their split
right with their separation and it was
designed to basically help her relax and
it was help her to help her kind of get
away from things she ends up feeding
Batman this kind of cocktail and says
this will basically flush the entire
toxin out of your system but be aware
man it's going to take you for one hell
of a
ride Harley's Quinn Harley Quinn like
her face turns into the Joker it like
her neck snaps sideways it just gets
wonky Batman starts losing his mind and
it's like okay like this like none of
this is real and then suddenly he's met
by the arrival of Alfred and it's like
you know I'm very sorry Master Bruce but
like I think it's time that we have a
very serious talk now we know Alfred's
not actually here but what this feels
like it's going to do is go into Alfred
and Batman and really kind of Batman
more or less having a conversation with
himself and it's going to elevate his
character and I'm very very excited to
see what this what this comic's going to
be about what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are continuing our coverage
of Joker War we are on part four and I
think it is I think it's part four we're
continuing the Joker
War so in the the last videos that we
did Batman had basically been exposed to
a kind of new version of The Joker toxin
that was created in large part through a
common combin effort of the Joker and
his new sidekick punch line but the
nature of this Joker toxin was that it
was exceedingly exceedingly potent far
stronger than than really any version
that we'd seen before and it was enough
to put Batman in a pretty deep sleep
right a pretty deep trance at least
strong enough to allow Joker to kind of
make his move and have Batman off the
board now Harley Quinn did come to the
rescue in so far as she was able to get
Batman out of Harm's Way but she had fed
him a kind of concoction that would help
him to overcome the serum in his body
and then bring him back right so he
could kind of go back and do his Batman
thing but what this does is this starts
up in the mind of Bruce Wayne himself
and it's almost kind of a throwback to
some old memories right in the sense
that he's kind of talking to Alfred and
talking about like the nature of the
batarangs in the sense that he made him
a little more streamlined to be
basically like shurikens but simply just
you know like like ninja stars more or
less but just a different look a
different design um and it's kind of
these this this interesting scenario
Mario because it seems to be in the
early days of when they were still
working with Lucius Fox but before
Lucius Fox knew that he was Batman and
so he kind of talks about how like they
might have to let Lucius in on what's
going on because you'll see his work on
the streets that kind of thing he also
talks about how he has a utility belt
and he was like by the end of all this
right the bat suit's just going to be
like one big utility belt I want to see
that I want to see like a bat suit
that's just nothing but Pockets but one
of the things that Alfred hits at is
that there's still a part of Batman that
believes that like he can save the day
right that that he's full of optimism
right that he's desperate to believe he
can be like the perfect Batman now this
is an important thing to understand is
because Alfred has kind of been a voice
that Bruce Wayne's been hearing ever
since he was exposed to the toxin even
when he was awake and he was still
struggling the nature of hearing
Alfred's voice was a way for him to kind
of focus the toxin into a singular point
to where it could still do its job but
it wouldn't really impact how he was
able to perform eventually it just
became too much right and between
fatigue and uh and the and the toxin
itself he ended up kind of succumbing to
it completely but this is again all kind
of a hallucination you know with regards
to Alfred and it's one of the things
that he says that that you know where
Batman realizes like you're not real
right you're dead Harley Quinn gave me
some tea to overcome this you know
Alfred kind of gives him this
perspective and says like you have a
weird gift that not many people who can
affect change have which just to say
you're able to use this moment to kind
of survey what's what you know what's
going on in your city from a bird's eye
view now it doesn't mean literally it
simply means that this is granting
Batman a repri it gives him a chance to
kind of look at the bigger picture see
everything that's happening and decide
what his worth is with you know with the
city of Gotham the various Heroes who
were there all that kind of stuff and so
while he's unconscious of course Harley
Quinn attending to him is suddenly met
by the arrival of punchline using this
as as kind of a chance to basically take
out Bruce Wayne Right to take out Harley
and to take out Bruce Wayne and so with
that being the case we sit back down
with Batman and Alfred and and the funny
thing is that the whole scenario with
Harley Quinn and punchline is actually
going to become a little bit of a
background thing here it'll be
relatively even but I think the main
brunt of this is really Bruce Wayne
himself and Alfred fixes in some some
tea right he says if we're going to have
tea we're going to do it properly right
and so he basically makes him a daring
blend and this is this is a tea that
Alfred served to Bruce Wayne whenever he
was stressed whenever he was frightened
whenever he was the most Disturbed from
a case that he was working on this
seemed to be especially important during
the early days of the Joker because the
Joker's crimes were so heinous and the
significance of this te as is explained
here is that it was Alfred's way of
telling Batman everything's going to be
okay that Bruce Wayne was too stubborn
and and really he he made himself too
hard of a person in a lot of ways to
really accept Alfred coming to him
putting his hand on his shoulder and
saying everything's going to be okay
Master Bruce and Bruce Wayne accepting
it and saying yeah you know and being
comforted by it he was on the inside he
just wouldn't really allow himself to
show it and so Alfred wouldn't really
tell him everything was going to be okay
in so many words instead he would make
him this tea and it was a kind of
unspoken conversation between the two
which is cool because it's designed to
show the closeness between Alfred and
Bruce right Alfred was a father figure
you know in in a lot of ways in almost
every important way and so you know he
he kind of asks Bruce Wayne like tell me
what's happening right tell me how bad
is all of this and the response of
Batman is the Joker is using all of his
money to tie up the legal system to keep
Joker's gangs on the streets he's
terrorizing people he's he's he's
literally taking people out right he's
taken the entire family fortune the
Wayne Manor Wayne Enterprises he had
Lucian Fox basically modify Vehicles
into into deadly Contraptions and so on
right like he's essentially conquered
Gotham and all of it's been paid for by
the Wayne foundation so the Bruce Wayne
Foundation or really just the Wayne
Foundation itself which was designed and
and serves the purpose of protecting and
making Gotham a better place is now
being used to tear it to the ground and
it's it's an important thing because
Alfred kind of comments like you've seen
this from the beginning right you know
the nature of the Joker from the
beginning the nature of the Joker is
he's he's cold he's disconnected right
he mocks everything that people love he
mocks family he mocks relationships all
that kind of stuff and he pulls his
allies closest to him as a mockery of
that right you have the you have you
have Robin he's got Harley Quinn and
Harley Quinn is designed to be a mockery
right you treat Robin as a kind of son
Dick Grayson was a surrogate son Tim
Drake Jason Todd Damen Wayne was a
biological son but you see your Robins
as as children and you take care of them
that way you make sure that they become
strong capable you raise them to become
productive members of society you teach
them right from wrong if they don't know
this is the kind of role that you play
Joker abuses his Sidekicks right he
treats them terribly he G he makes life
rough for them he puts them in
situations that could very well cost
them their lives he's a mockery to
everything that you believe but there's
one massive difference between you and
him for the Joker taking one life is no
different than taking a million if it
means he can get to you but this is
different for you you value the sanctity
of life you understand the importance of
family and friends these things are
relevant to you and so you end up
switching back to hard and punchline and
the fight between these two is pretty
straightforward Right Punch Line's got
like a flamethrower she's just like you
know torching this whole place and
Harley Quinn's like shooting the place
up right and and for the most part it's
kind of round two but there is a cool
discussion here between these two
characters Harley Quinn sees punchline
as kind of a in a continuation of
herself right in the sense that there's
a little bit of a conversation that goes
on you know when you have punchline kind
of you know fighting against Harley she
makes a a comment about the nature of
Harley right that Harley thinks she's
somebody special that she thinks she was
somebody unique but she's not that in
the end like the story of Harley is just
kind of this this boring mundane
uninspiring story right like Harley
Quinn was she was this young girl you
know who thought she was destined to do
something great with her life you know
and then she wanted to do something
great for people she wanted to help
people and so on and so she ended up
getting a job working in Arkham Asylum
and she met the Joker and the Joker
swindled her he tricked her he convinced
her he was a sensitive guy she got
caught up in the whole thing she ended
up becoming a sidekick and then
basically ended up leaving right you
know what she kind of tells Harley is
like you're a basic Becky there's
nothing interesting about you right
you're not intriguing you're just some
girl who got her heartbroken by a crazy
guy and now that you left you think
you're somehow Cut From a Different
Cloth like no you're you're basic
there's nothing intriguing about you
she's like I on the other hand I saw the
world for what it was right the world
was going crazy and people were
pretending like it wasn't the world was
falling apart it was going to pieces and
people were just kind of looking around
and saying no everything's okay as if
they said it enough times it would be
true and then she heard the Joker speak
she heard him talk she heard this this
guy who was talking about how like the
world is crazy and the world was was
nuts you know and the only way to
survive it was to be as insane as he was
that he in a lot of ways kind of offered
this this vocalized speech on how
punchline saw the world and she found
herself enamored with it the funny thing
about this is that is the story of
Harley Quinn that's the thing that's
what punchline doesn't grasp her story
is the story of Harley Quinn right it's
being caught up by a different means but
it's being caught up nonetheless she
thinks she's special when she's not and
that's what Harley tries to tell her
like I thought the Joker had a heart you
think he has a brain but at the end of
the day everybody's a means to an end
right like the Joker doesn't care about
anybody but himself and man that's it
that's the only thing he cares about he
doesn't care about who he has to hurt
who he has to sacrifice who he has to
put In Harm's Way as long as it gets him
to the bat what you haven't figured out
is that you're not special right like
you think you are but you're not you
believe that you can change him or you
believe that somehow you're special in
this this unique way to where only you
can truly understand him like you're
literally just a victim like you've got
a victim complex but at some point in
time you're going to come to an
understanding of your place in the world
you're going to realize you're not as
special as you think you are and that's
that's kind of a crazy theme because it
almost seems like what Quinn says
impacts punchline and she thinks it's
true because she's like you believe
you're wrong and I'll prove you're wrong
right like I'll show you what the Joker
really believes once I kill Batman
myself and that's her mistake right
that's that's the obvious instance that
she doesn't truly understand the Joker
because if she did she would know that
the Joker Joker doesn't want to kill
Batman right like that's not the whole
idea that joker loves the cat and mouse
game he loves the idea of Batman chasing
him that's that's what he digs right
that that that's his whole stick and so
if she kills Batman the Joker's probably
going to kill her just out of Wrath just
out of anger and so you switch back to
Alfred you switch back to to Bruce Wayne
and one of the things Alfred says here
this is probably one of the most amazing
conversations one of the most amazing
things that Alfred brings up right he
says you take yourself too seriously
master Bruce right but Batman is a
child's dream you can travel the world
and learn every possible way to save
everybody that's a child's perception
only a child would look at that and
think that it's actually possible but
once you get out into the real world
once you learn the the limitations of
humanity you realize that you can't do
it on your own but the dream is still
possible in the sense that yes you can
save everybody you just need the help of
others to do it and he says like you you
you've spent too much time trying to
save my life because you won't accept
that I'm dead you've pushed away the
people that remind you of that fact you
hold it against Damen Wayne Right Damen
Wayne was the one who went into Gotham
during the city of Bane and and was
despite being told if the bat family
enters here I will kill Alfred Damien
was the one who believed that he could
say Alfred he went into the city he
basically broke the truce that led to to
Damen Wayne once he was captured seeing
Alfred killed right in front of him
Batman holds it against Damen saying
like if if you hadn't gone into Gotham
then he never would have died you hold
it against Dick Grayson because he was
shot in the head so he became Rick
Grayson one of the worst story ARS ever
but like he became somebody who wasn't
wasn't de gracing he wasn't his normal
self you held it against Selena for
making you feel like it was never safe
for you to come home that you you felt
like you couldn't really trust anybody
you hold it against everybody else but
the reality and and this is what Bruce
Wayne kind of accepts he says like I
failed and that's when Alfred just
freaks out and slaps him across the face
and he's like the story's not over man
like you're Batman right you have to
accept the world world that you that you
live in and you have to accept what you
can control there are things in Gotham
that you can't control you can't make
people be good guys you can't make
people do things differently the only
thing you can control is how you operate
as Batman how you inspire people but
some things are beyond your ability to
control here you have to accept that you
did not and you cannot save me you were
in a place where you couldn't get to me
you didn't know what Damian did you
didn't know that I was being held by
Bane and you didn't know that he was
going to kill me so you can't hold
yourself for that you can't say like
it's my fault that Alfred died you
didn't know what could you have possibly
done right you did not and you cannot
save your parents you were a little kid
you didn't know that leaving the theater
and your father taking that shortcut
would lead to them being killed but even
if you tried what could you have
possibly done in the face of a gun at 12
years old like you you have to stop
holding yourself accountable for these
things right you can't hold hold these
things against yourself there's nothing
you could have done but you can save
yourself and in doing so you can save
the lives of so many other people in the
city that you love so much and he says
that's what's important every life that
you save is a victory against death
against the Joker if you truly want to
defeat the Joker if you truly want to
beat him then be the opposite of what
the Joker stands for if the Joker is
death be life if the Joker is chaos be
order be these things be be what matters
most in this world and so he tells them
right like wake up you know where where
where Batman says like I don't know if I
can do this without you the response of
Alfred is I'm always here you've known
me your entire life you don't need me on
the other side of a of a microphone to
know what I would tell you you don't
need to hear me tell you that you're
doing a great job you you don't need to
hear me tell you that I'm proud of you
you know that because you know me and
you know what would make me proud what
would make me proud is seeing you go
forward live your life save yourself and
make something of the city of Gotham
Batman snaps up right immediately wakes
up as soon as punchline gets to him let
me tell you something man this was a
girl that was getting a little big for
her britches right like she thought she
could take on Batman you serious not a
chance right like Batman wakes up and
he's like okay so like uh this this
we're playing a different game now this
toxin that was in my system is gone now
right this toxin is totally out of me
and I'm right back to 100% again if you
want to do this dance girl we can do
this dance but understand I've done this
dance with a lot of people right and
it's it's like Bane said from The Dark
Knight Returns like Shipwrecked men
turning to seawater due to
uncontrollable thirst many have died
trying and so punchline get subdued
pretty quickly right and then after that
it's like okay let's take care of this
and so he's like I need to reactivate my
communication systems well the problem
with this is that he fried his circuits
back when he was at the theater and then
of course we get the most Batman
response ever don't underestimate what I
can fit in this belt and then he's like
I called the battery right it's just
kind of like a backup system and he
basically and Harley Quinn is just like
no come on man like you know it's like
it's like computer right this is Batman
get me the location of the family and
it's like which family members do you
want and he's like I need everybody cute
a Catwoman right Catwoman's like I got
to go I got to bounce right so she's
part of the bat family she gets the
message from Batman that Bruce Wayne is
back she goes to leave the the hotel
right the the club of the penguin right
this kind of plac this on lockdown while
they ride out the whole Joker attack and
she's like you guys need to come with me
and they're like why would we leave in
the midst of a joker attack right I mean
it's one of these cool things where it's
like everybody knows how dangerous The
Joker Is and she's like what if I told
you that I can make you and Edward nigma
billionaires if you guys come with me
the sound of money most people will buy
into that sound what's going on guys
this is Rob we're picking up with uh
Batman number 100 right so this is the
conclusion to Joker War and the cool
thing about this is that this initially
picks up really with like Burnside right
the clock tower in Burnside and the
reason why that matters is because this
is basically Oracle making her return
Oracle is an interesting concept right
because Oracle has people who love her
to death and they have people who just
don't like her at all but the idea
behind this was that after Barbara
Gordon was shot during the killing joke
and then once DC rolled that concept
over into the main DC Universe so it
became basically an aspect of her
history they basically kind of gave her
this role of Oracle where she was
essentially an information broker and
that's where actually a lot of people
were introduced to Barbara Gordon in
that role and so because of that she
kind of has a a pretty cool fan base as
Oracle which is a pretty interesting
part of her character but she hasn't
really played that role for quite some
time but basically what's end up
happening here is that because the
emergency services are all kind of being
put in stasis to a degree by the
officials in Gotham City due to you know
legal work and all that kind of stuff
with everything going on basically tying
up the City by tying up the courts what
Barbara Gordon does is she actually goes
on to a to a kind of a kind of broadcast
of sorts you know and literally hijacks
the city's you know radio waves their
the radio frequencies and basically says
like Joker conquer you know Joker
conquered Gotham City and that any
chance the city has to fight back is
basically being you know being uh kept
at Bay by all the the the web of money
and Corruption right that's that's
literally paralyzing the mayor and the
various Ci's institutions right that
like the mayor is on the payroll all
these lawyers and stuff like that like
they're all crooked people like they're
all corrupt and crooked people and
because of their corruption that this is
where we are now right that like
literally money's able to kind of to
keep things stopped keep things locked
in place and that's what allows the city
to be conquered and so what she says is
like stay inside right like don't go to
any movie theaters all the movie
theaters are death traps but stay inside
and basically keep your doors locked
right and I'm sending you guys a kind of
a kind of an emergency number that you
can contact in case you need help and if
that time comes contact it and we'll
send somebody there to help you now in
the face of that what happens is like
one of the officers basically shows up
to uh to Harvey bulock and says like
you've got to stand down right like the
mayor is ordering you to stand down like
you have to you have to you know
basically shut the entire Oracle system
down right like what oracle's doing here
you have to disable all of that now of
course this is done because the mayor's
crooked and so when that happens like
he's basically told like the mayor's
saying if you don't do this it's going
to be your job and so ultimately bulock
just quits right he takes his badge he
throws it on the ground he says look
guys that's my answer right like we've
got a crooked mayor running the show so
here's the question that we have to ask
ourselves do we want to be be cops in
this crooked City or do we want to do
what's right the right thing to do is to
help people is to keep this broadcast
system going right the mayor is just one
man and the power he has is only
relevant because we allow him to have it
but what happens if we don't allow him
to have that power anymore then what is
he just a man in a suit in a room
somewhere hoping that people will listen
to him and that's basically it and so in
the aftermath of that you end up having
you know you kind of switch over to to
to Dick Grayson right to Nightwing who's
kind of doing his thing and and you know
beating the crap out of criminals but
there's also a little bit of banter
going back and forth between himself and
and Barbara Gordon in the sense that for
him he's like man it's actually kind of
nice to hear you back again like in the
the seat of Oracle making sure that
we're safe and that we're able to to do
our things as we're supposed to it's
kind of a cool little thing right and so
the question is has anybody heard
anything from from Bruce Wayne Right has
anybody heard anything from Batman and
the response of Barb is no he's probably
got bigger things to worry about and
that's when we switch back over to
basically the Joker wearing his Batman
costume facing off against Batman and
this is one of these these really really
cool scenarios where like the Joker
makes these exceedingly Salient points
right these amazing points he's kind of
going on and on and rambling about
nonsense right that's what the Joker
does right the Joker just kind of gets
under your skin by going on about
nonsense or at least that's the initial
response one of the funny things is is
Joker makes this comment where or he
asked Batman he's like he's like you
really hate guns don't you he's like I
used to think that you hated those
because you were just boring but I'm
starting to understand why it's amazing
how many explosives you can fit inside
these little toys of yours why buy a gun
when you can just put little bombs
inside your utility
belt which is actually a good point and
so of course this leads to you know
these small little explosives kind of
detonating off right and the Joker toxin
kind of going everywhere you know your
standard Fair of of Batman versus Joker
sort of stuff but then like Batman
starts to get frustrated at the Joker
and and the reason why is because Joker
starts to basically make all the these
different these different scenarios he
literally hits up Barbara Gordon and or
at least Batman hits up Barbara Gordon
starts talking to her the Joker's
response is that's cheating right it's
supposed to be just you and me uh and
it's a good thing that one of these
devices killed your radio so you can't
really call for backup you know and he
says otherwise you know these weird
little orphans that you keep collecting
would have to listen to their dear old
bad dad get stabbed to death Batman gets
frustrated and and Joker's like be
honest you're it's a costume right I
look as stupid as you do and they they
kind of keep going back and forth Batman
takes out the lights and then Joker
basically uses his ability to see in the
dark and then literally you know Batman
gets the upper hand on Joker and and it
just kind of goes back and forth back
and forth back and forth right now
before we kind of get to this really
really cool moment here I do want to
Sidetrack for a second right and I want
to focus on punchline punchline was kind
of a of a of a plot threat that was sort
of left dangling and if this was comic
books 30 years ago it would have just
stayed left dangling right it just never
would have been wrapped up such as it is
in this day and age they're pretty good
about wrapping up plot threads right and
so what you end up basically getting is
is you know Joker when he detonates a
portion of the factory the punchline
realizes that wasn't supposed to
happened yet right and so like something
like that was supposed to be the next
step something's going on so then she
starts trying to get a hold of the
clowns none of them are answering and in
the midst of all that you basically have
under broker who walks in and says like
we have to bring our association to the
to an end right like I'm no no longer
going to be able to help you continue to
push back the various lawyers and and
keep the city kind of locked up you know
in in legal hell like I'm not going to
be able to do that anymore uh so you're
going to have to vacate the premises
immediately or I will call the
authorities and that's in her
frustration she doesn't have anybody to
help her out you know to to cope with
this and so in the midst of all that you
know she seems to basically leave a
message for a joker right you know kind
of telling him what's going on but then
you have Nightwing who shows up and
Nightwings you know this is the first
time that Nightwing and punchliner
meeting and it's actually an interesting
encounter right he's like my name's
Nightwing we haven't really met been out
of town for a little bit and what was
probably one of the worst story lines
involving my character and you're going
to go to prison tonight right like
that's basically what it is you're know
you're going to go to prison for the
rest of your life punchline tries to
fight back and the the first thing
Nightwing says is you're not up against
someone who forgot a lifetime of
training right like you're up against me
and literally just like this fight ends
like that it ends like quick fast and in
a hurry she calls in a whole bunch of
clowns Nightwing ends up calling in the
bat family everything's over pretty fast
right like it all gets wrapped up pretty
quickly and so you end up switching back
over to Barbara Gordon right to Oracle
who basically hits up Batman and says
hey look uh so and I guess his device is
working now right but he's like you know
we basically got the city back in back
in a a state of of array right we got
everything back to the way it's supposed
to be like for the most part the clowns
are neutralized punch lines neutralized
we're getting Law and Order back into
the city right like everything's
starting to calm back down and and
that's when you kind of have this this
funny thing where the Joker's like but
you can't win like Batman tells the
Joker like like we've already taken back
the city you're not going to get your
War and the Joker's response was like
don't you get it like you missed the war
right like I already won you have to be
smart enough to have figured that out
already right like I've already won I've
already taken the day we're in the
aftermath here right this joke this this
war has been over for quite some time
and he says you have to understand
whatever future that you dreamed of
Gotham City being it's it's a future
that you're never going to get Gotham
City is a sick place a twisted place
right it's messed up nobody want nobody
here is good nobody here or there's no
inherently good people in the city of
Gotham it's not the way that it works
the city's tired of you it's tired of
the fact that you failed them like it's
tired of it's tired of everything that
you represent right like you are not a
citizen of Gotham Batman despite the
fact that you would want to believe
you're not one of them you're a rich guy
you're the richest one of the richest
men in the world and you live in a
mansion outside the city limits how are
you part of Gotham City right it's it's
interesting because it's like it reminds
me of that scene from Batman Begins
right where you have that they have that
moment when you have um God what was his
name it was Tom Wilkinson who played the
the mob boss guy but like Bruce Wayne
goes walking into like his his little
you know bar area or whatever it is and
and like starts spouting off about how
like he's going to go to jail and all
that kind of stuff you know and Tom
Wilkinson's like he's like pointing
around he's saying there's all these
different different things here you know
there's a congressman and a judge and y
y y That's power you can't buy but he
says like you think because your mommy
and your daddy got shot that you really
understand what the darker side of life
is it's like you don't understand the
darker side of life you're Bruce Wayne
you're the prince of Gotham you'd have
to drive a thousand miles to find
somebody who doesn't know your name like
you've never tasted desperate you've
never tasted suffering you've never
really known poverty like you've never
really known any of those things you
think you have but you haven't you've
known somewhat those things right and
and it's a it's a good point because
that really is Bruce Wayne Right Bruce
Wayne is trying to relate to people he
could never really relate to he doesn't
know desperate he doesn't know suffering
right he doesn't know hopelessness like
he he knows I can always come out on top
you know and that's kind of the nature
of things is the Joker looks at it and
says like you tried to pretend that
Gotham City is a nice place but it's an
angry city right it's a hungry City it's
a dangerous city and he says with
everything that I've done here now
people look at Wayne Enterprises they
don't see them as a place that's here to
help them they see it as a place that
stands against them that it's the same
sort of corrupt corporate Enterprise
that exists out there in so many other
companies because it is all it took was
a little bit of money and suddenly the
the wheels of of Wayne Enterprises just
came to a screeching halt all it took
was a little bit of money in the city of
of Gotham and look how quickly those
politicians and those judges and so on
sucked it all up right just a little bit
of money was able to bring this whole
city to a stand still just imagine that
like nobody has any faith in anything
anymore and why should they why should
they have faith in you why should they
have faith in Gotham City why should
they have faith in any of that right
like a little bit of money brought this
whole city to its knees and despite all
the politicians claims of I'm here for
the Working Man and I'm here for you and
I'm here for you and so on and so forth
and despite all your best efforts to say
like you're here for the average
gothamite one you're not really a
gothamite because you don't see yourself
as part of Gotham because you live
outside of Gotham and then two nobody
trusts those politicians anymore because
at the first chance they got they turn
their back on people for money right
like nobody has any faith in anybody in
anything anymore nobody has any faith in
in the city of Gotham they don't have
any faith in you they don't have any
faith in anything right they're just
kind of making it through this world and
doing things and then whatever happens
happens and it makes sense right it's a
reasonable expectation to have in the in
the face of all of this in the face of
like all that struggle and all that
suffering why wouldn't you just give up
it makes the most sense it's the most
practical thing to do the funny thing
about this is that in the in the midst
of of B of Joker's great big huge rant
his great big huge rant his great big
huge tiate Harley Quinn pops up right
you know bust a shot through Joker's eye
so basically shoots him in the eye you
know and it's just kind of like I used
your face as target practice for a long
time but the funny thing is you remember
the the the agreement that Harley Quinn
made with Batman if you get in there and
it looks like you're starting to lose
I'm going to take over and that's
exactly what she does she brings in
these bombs that she had brought from uh
Bel reef and she basically puts one on
her ties one to her chest and she ties
one to the Joker and then she tells
Batman you're going to have to make a
choice either you're going to save me
and let Joker die or you're going to let
me die and you're going to save the
Joker you got to do one of these two
things right but what you do will show
what kind of person you are do you
really want Gotham City to be better or
do you want Gotham City to be worse do
you want it to be the way it's always
been do you want this to continue to be
a version of Gotham City where
everything sucks and you sacrifice
innocent lives because you don't believe
in killing a guy who's going to kill
innocent people right like the life of
one man is worth more than the lives of
a few thousand people and and you know
she's like that's the choice you have to
make now right you're going to have to
let somebody die here either you let me
die or you let the Joker die but if
you're not willing to do what needs to
be done to make this city better then I
will try to force your hand right I will
try to make you be the person who has to
actually get off this this fence and
make a decision and so she just runs
right she just goes she just takes off
running with these bombs Batman
initially says given the technology you
know that you have from the bat suit you
could disarm this bomb if you wanted to
and the Joker's like that's not how it
works right so right off the bat Batman
gives Joker an out which shows Batman
wants to save the Joker which shows that
knowing what Joker is going to do
Batman's okay with letting innocent
people die so long as the Joker so long
as he doesn't kill the Joker right
Batman's afraid of you know becoming
worse you know so on so it's okay to let
those innocent people die kind of after
that moment he's like no no no no that's
not how this works right Harley Quinn
made the rules of this game and the
rules of this game State you either have
to save her and deactivate her bomb or
you have to save me and deactivate my
bomb but you can't deactivate both and
Batman's like okay then and then he just
walks away he goes after Harley Quinn
and just leaves Joker there so it's like
my God Batman like thank God like you
actually made a choice right like you
actually decided to kill a person is it
a slippery slope not if you don't let it
be
not if you just say like the Joker was
just that bad there are no villains in
the world as bad as the Joker the number
of innocent lives he took the fact that
he turned the entire city into a raging
mad house with this Joker toxin
everything that's happened here he kind
of deserved to die right so I mean is it
a slippery slope am I going to go become
a guy who's just going to kill every
single criminal that I come across no
why because not all of them were as bad
as Joker like he was literally the worst
of the worst and so because of that like
when he's walking away right I I feel
like I should just kind of nip that bud
that uh that slippery slow argument
which is like the easiest argument in
the world to crush but I felt like I
should just kind of crush that argument
real quick but like with with Batman
like walking away the Joker starts
getting pissed off right he's like don't
just walk away man he's like you got to
stay here the the Alfred corpse right
Falls at Falls at at Joker starts
laughing manically Joker starts getting
pissed off bomb goes off right so we end
up picking up like a week later this is
kind of the crazy thing we pick up a
week later with Harley Quinn in the
hospital and Batman's talking to her you
know she's like she's like you know I
had this weird dream with like this girl
that didn't have like a funny name she
was kind of an idiot right and she
thought she could fight but she couldn't
and she got the upper hand on me once
because you know like a sucker punch and
so it's it's it's kind of this this this
little thing where she's rambling a bit
but she's like how long have I been out
and Batman's like you've been out for a
week and that's kind of the crazy thing
is one of the first things she she she
thinks is like he's really dead like you
really did kill the Joker you know and
and the response of Batman is no like I
found his bomb intact it was deactivated
basically he took Batman's advice and
deactivated the bomb so Batman is the
reason why the Joker got out I mean I
guess you know Batman fans you know
Batman fans are like Batman right like
they always find a way to support Batman
they're always like there's always a way
to win so I can guarantee in this
instance they'll say well Batman told
Joker that he already knew that so
Batman didn't really save Joker Joker
saved himself you know so I'm sure
Batman fans will say that but
nonetheless Harley's kind of response is
like I'm glad he's dead right like I'm
glad he's dead I'm glad it's done you
know and and the city really kind of
seems to have changed in a different way
but for Batman he seems to have changed
in a different way right like all this
crap that he's gone through right like
all this garbage that he's gone through
all the stuff that he's had to put up
with for his whole life seemingly you
know like this is his chance to be
better right it's his chance to finally
get away from that his chance to finally
move away from like all that crappiness
and become the best version of himself
the question you have to ask here is is
it going to last I'm afraid it won't
right I'm I'm really afraid that it
won't but you know he's basically like I
think I could be a better Batman than I
was before right not so harsh not so
intense not so judgmental I guess you
know really more more willing to listen
that kind of a thing like a Sofer
gentler Batman which really kind of begs
the question how's I going to help crime
it's like the person who doesn't believe
in guns versus the person who does if
you're a person who doesn't believe in
guns it doesn't change the fact that the
person standing there has a gun in your
face so you're going to do something
about it or you just going to try to
talk them down with harsh language but
nonetheless uh from there we kind of
pick up with this epilogue right the
small little moment you know we
basically have this kind of person who's
sort of looking around and basically
says like look at look at what a mess
you've made of Gotham City right like
our teachers would be so ashamed of you
this is a new character that we're
getting this person basically says like
it's time your city had a choice in its
protector the truce is over right it's
time for Gotham to meet the ghost maker
so there's like another person who's
showing up here in Gotham with the
intention of like wrestling against
Batman for the one who's going to run
the show right it's really really cool
which I'm excited to
see all right what's going on guys this
is Rob and we are picking up with the
aftermath 2 Joker war and this kind of
start of a whole new Batman and this is
cool if I'm being honest with you guys I
love this this new direction that DC's
taking Batman in and if I'm being honest
I kind of feel like it's a long time
coming to be honest with you guys and
and and you guys will see what I mean by
the time we get to the end of this but
initially this this kind of picks up
with a bit of musing on behalf of Bruce
Wayne Right in the aftermath and
everything that's gone on it's a little
bit of musing here and he talks about
how the way things used to be right back
in the day and when I say back in the
day I mean for quite some time in DC
Comics really since like the
introduction of Batman in the very early
days in the sense that when we had
Commissioner Gordon when we had the
introduction of the bat signal when you
had Alfred that things kind of follow
this pattern that Bruce Wayne would
begin his night you know as Batman he
put on his cloak on cowl he'd go out
into the City and then like the bad
signal might come up right and that was
just kind of an indicator of hey things
are popping off come and see me uh
Commissioner Gordon would say that you
know come and see me and I'll kind of
give you the skinny on what's happening
throughout Gotham as a whole now once
Bruce Wayne was given this rundown it'd
be left to him to decide which one
needed the most attention basically
right and once he narrowed that down he
kind of investigate the various Clues
somehow sometimes he would do this with
Robin other times he would do it by
himself he'd have Alfred in his ear kind
of giving him some advice and and you
know as an outside perspective uh he'd
get back to the Batcave Alfred would
basically push him to eat or drink
something but Batman would always have
this idea of if I stay here and
investigate long enough I can kind of
put the clues together and I can solve
this case and that was the Form and
Function by which everything in Gotham
City worked and then seemingly over the
course of a single night or over the
course of an exceedingly short period of
time all that went away Alfred died
commissioner Gordon's out of the picture
the the Joker who managed to
successfully take over Gotham City
Batman's lost pretty much all of his
resources right it's kind of just him
and and a lot of this this discussion
that he has really you know really comes
from Selena Kyle and that's when she's
kind of like I can see that look on your
face it drives it drives me insane I
hate it it's that you've made a decision
and it's going to change both of our
lives and it's the right decision to
make but you know that it's going to
suck in terms of this decision and
initial thought was Batman's calling it
off right he's basically telling Selena
like we're no longer together anymore
the reality of this is he basically kind
of says Joker was right I've been doing
this I've been doing this all wrong for
a very long time and that's true right
Batman's been doing this wrong for a
very very lengthy amount of time right
and and the way this the reason why this
kind of comes out picks up about a week
ago and we basically end up picking up
with grifter now the reality is that
grifter is a character I don't really
know a whole lot about I know enough to
know that he comes from the Wild Storm
imprint which was created by uh by by
Jim Lee and Brandon Troy back in the day
back in the '90s and he was part of a
group called International operations I
think it was kind of like an Espionage
spy team Wild Storm was largely its own
Universe it was just kind of out there
doing its own thing in the aftermath of
flasho and the launch of the new 52 Wild
Storm became part of the main DC line of
comics but that's really all I know
about grifter and honestly I don't
really care that much to know anything
more about him he's not interesting to
me I don't really care much about his
character for the long and short of it
for the sake of this video since it you
know this channel really is designed to
educate you guys the nature of grifter
is such that he he has powers in so far
as as telekinetic abilities he's
exceedingly fast he's a great con artist
right he was a uh he was a a member of
the US military Special Ops Team or
group or whatever you want to call it
before he deserted and became a con man
effectively he was at one point involved
with a group of aliens called demonit or
demonit I'm not 100% sure how to
pronounce that they basically tried to
possess him to take over his physical
form uh he ended up escaping and then
for the most part he's just kind of been
somewhat of a wonderer I think and
really more of just kind of like a Hired
Gun like a mercenary uh but in this
particular instance here he's basically
working as a bodyguard for lucious Fox
right now Batman's aware of who grifter
is the fight between them is really
interesting and and if anything I think
it's really one of these attempts by DC
to say hey guys like look at this guy
grifter you know he's he's pretty
interesting um I don't think anybody's
really buying it but uh he's he's
capable enough to where he can kind of
fight Batman to a standstill but he's
basically been hired as a bodyguard by
Lucius Fox and the reason for this is as
part of the hold over with regards to
Joker War Lucius Fox is still the person
in possession of Batman's wealth right
of Bruce Wayne's wealth and really kind
of the guy running Wayne Enterprises now
in in the videos that we do where we do
like a character explanation or team
explanation or something like that we'll
talk about stories that happen over the
course of a character's publication
history that basically changes things up
that kind of initiates a huge status quo
that's what this is right this is a
massive status quo change for Batman and
so you guys are literally reading
history in real time in this particular
instance right for those you guys who
bought the book who are reading it right
now you're reading through history like
a huge history change in real time how
long it lasts we don't really know but
the idea behind this is that with Lucius
Fox more or less kind of running the
show here effectively being a
billionaire there's a few things going
on the first is that he still Harbors
some ill will towards Batman in the
sense that everything that happened with
Joker War uh you know the the way that
he was infected by Joker Toxin and all
that kind of stuff the experience has
left him largely with some measure of
PTSD now the other part of that is we
kind of get this indication that
punchline is still around that she's
kind of out there talking to the press
and things like that that was DC teasing
us with an idea of punch Line's
miniseries or maybe her ongoing series
I'm not really sure but the other part
of that is you still have clown Hunter
and clown Hunter is still basically
going through tracking down members who
are part of Joker's gang and then taking
them out where he finds them now the
reason why this matters is because in
the aftermath of Joker war in the fall
of the Joker those individuals who were
part of his army vanished because their
leader was effectively gone and their
their chance of success right their
chance of of kind of having the world as
they wanted it to be actually coming to
fruition was gone right so it was
basically you guys lost and in that
instance you know in that case they
basically took off and they they backed
down right they they ended up basically
kind of going underground and that's an
important distinction to understand here
there's a difference between quitting
and just going to a place where you
can't be detected and that's basically
what was happening here for the the
Joker's Army in terms of putting on the
masks and going on going out every night
and doing things that's over right they
don't really do that anymore instead
they meet underground they meet in
places that are not easily found and
then plot or plan accordingly now the
Joker's still out there and as far as
we're aware The Joker doesn't really
have any involvement with his own gang
because as we know as the reader The
Joker doesn't really care about those
guys they believe the Joker cares and
they they hope the Joker cares but the
Joker doesn't really care about them
they were Canon fodder right they were a
means to achieve an end now whether or
they were intelligent enough to realize
that is a wholly different beast and in
times of desperation people believe what
they want to believe and what ended up
happening here is you had people who
wanted things to be a certain way the
Joker represented that way and
ultimately they kind of tied the two
together of their own volition The Joker
saying things I like and and the Joker
is espousing ideologies I agree with
therefore the Joker agrees with me the
Joker likes me and and the result of
that is they ended up kind of becoming
the people that they were becoming now
the Joker basically kind of falling
Joker having been defeated or at the
very least a scheme ending kind of put
puts them in a position to where it's
well the Joker still out there The Joker
will save us you know I'm I'm kind of
making some assumptions here but you
know it's it's it's interesting it
basically means that Joker's Army is not
wh dead albeit very much you know much
smaller than it used to be but the long
and short of this is that there are some
major things going on with Bruce Wayne
and especially Wayne man Wayne Wayne
Enterprises and Lucius Fox that Lucius
Fox to a degree kind of enjoys the idea
of having all this wealth you know he
goes as far as to say I'm not going to
lie lie to you and say that like it's
fine you know that that that you know I
don't want this money it doesn't benefit
me it does it benefits me it benefits my
family that's the truth of the matter
right having these funds at my disposal
but understand that Wayne Enterprises is
looking to force you out right like you
are a member of the board but they're
looking to basically give you like a
huge chunk of change let you just kind
of draw income seemingly for the rest of
your life and then you go away but you
basically end up stepping down from when
Enterprises as part of the board you
have no decision-making ability anymore
more so than that the reason why is
because the heat's on to you right the
government is looking at you one of the
big things that came out of Joker war
was how how Bruce Wayne was spending his
money offshore accounts different things
like that and so the IRS and the
financial sector of the federal
government right so seemingly the Secret
Service if there's any indication of
fraud on a massive level being invoked
they're looking into Bruce Wayne and so
the more he's in the public eye the more
heat and scrutiny he draws on the Wayne
Enterprises and so it's best for
business that Bruce Wayne stepped down
and that's the one of the big reasons
why Lucius Fox is kind of holding on to
this money the other part of that is
that the notion the the public
perception out there that Bruce Wayne is
a person who was potentially engaging an
embezzlement or at the very least tax
fraud right like you know or or even
just dodging taxes is not good for the
public for for public perception of
Wayne Enterprises and so one of the
other reasons why they wanted to step
down is so that they can Rebrand right
they can Rebrand Wayne Enterprises right
all new all different Wayne Enterprises
or something like that hopefully not as
bad as what Marvel did and you know the
aftermath of Secret Wars but the whole
point behind that is they're looking to
literally distance themselves from Bruce
Wayne and so the important thing behind
this and the reason why this matters is
that Bruce Wayne cannot operate as
Batman the the way he's done in the past
which is to say with a unlimited
checkbook and all the high-tech gadgetry
in the world that at the end Batman's
going to have to operate on the most
basic level there's no high-tech
gadgetry there's no super Advanced
Batmobiles with all the resources in the
world that just come off of some endless
supply chain it doesn't work that way
anymore that he's got a Batmobile if the
Batmobile breaks down he's got to fix it
now there's a couple reasons for why
this is happening the first is because
at this point it's obvious DC's bringing
Batman comics more in line with Robert
Patterson's Batman film the other part
of this is because we've seen this
happen before the most notable instance
came in 1969 during the Frank Robbins
and Edmund Hamilton ERA with Batman
number 27 and this was a point where
Dick Grayson had basically left to go to
college and the result of this is that
uh Bruce Wayne actually ended up leaving
Wayne Manor and taking up residence in
the city of Gotham and the reason why
that's important is because what you end
up having here is this conversation
between himself and Selena Kyle where he
says that's what I want to do now one of
the one of the little moments that comes
out of this this is really more of a
plot Point that'll be important later on
is that when Bruce Wayne ends up leaving
uh leaving Lucius Fox right leaving that
office he tells grifter like send a
message to your boss right and tell like
send a message to Lucius Fox tell him I
know what Halo is and basically I'm
watching it looks like it's you know
some kind of little bit of an
underground thing some kind of plot
point that we'll see later on down the
line but kind of picking back up with
Bruce Wayne and Selena Kyle again he
basically says I'm going to move into
the city itself and that's what he did
in the aftermath really with Batman 27
he ended up moving into a penthouse
inside Gotham City and that was designed
more for him to be closer to the ground
to be more more direct the the issue
with this is that in the aftermath of
that he ended up deciding that being so
close to the city was not the best idea
because it was too easy for people to
pick up and distinguish the fact that
Bruce Wayne was Batman right they were
seeing him every day people could find a
way to break in different things like
that and putting the pieces together was
seemingly just too easy so it didn't
last all that long and I would say if
this does remain a main stay for James
tenon's run once he leaves he'll go back
to Wayne Manor right and then we'll
probably find some way in which you know
Alfred comes back probably using the
Lazarus pits you know who really knows
but the the the the whole point behind
this is that he basically says like
there's a brownstone there that I own
and I didn't even realize that I owned
it so I'm certainly going to move into
it I'm not going to live across the
bridge I'm going to live inside the city
that I want to protect so again kind of
reiterating what we've seen happen in
years past when it came to Batman the
funny thing about this is that he had
actually considered the idea of Selen
Kyle kind of renaming herself right like
creating a new identity and her working
alongside Bruce Wayne the issue with
this is that with Selena Kyle and Bruce
Wayne spending time together and then
Catwoman and Batman hanging out together
people would have put the pieces
together like that they would have done
it so quick and they would have said
Bruce Wayne and Selena Kyle are hanging
out all the time Batman and Catwoman are
fighting crime together all the time is
Bruce Wayne and Selena Kyle Batman and
Catwoman somebody somewhere would have
figured that out right the funny thing
about this though is that Selena Kyle
had the reverse idea that Bruce Wayne
could just run off with her now of
course Bruce's response is I can't do
that and that's true right how's DC
going to publish Batman comics if Bruce
Wayne's not Batman it doesn't
work nobody wants to read a a a Batman
comic where Bruce Wayne's not Batman for
for like 10 years for a short amount of
time sure right like the whole aftermath
of final crisis you know where like Dick
Grayson was Batman for a time and Damen
Wayne was Robin sure that's interesting
the aftermath of Batman Nightfall sure
but in terms of like 2030 that like
Bruce Wayne is still not Batman people
don't want that people want Bruce Wayne
to be Batman Forever right it's just
kind of the the way things are it's the
way comic book fans are we do not like
change and so it's one of these things
where where Bruce Wayne basically and
and even Selena Selena Kyle basically
say like we need to to kind of get
ourselves reground right like we need to
we need to reground ourselves and so
what's interesting about this is like
you know Selena Kyle is like we'll take
one year basically one year apart one
year for them to figure things out to
get them uh get things grounded to get
themselves sorted out and then at the
end of that one year basically reconcile
consolidate and see whether or not they
can move forward together and so what
you kind of end up getting is then
basically going to the brownst of Bruce
Wayne and knocking boots right I mean
there's no apart no no furniture in
there m Len C's like who needs furniture
but nonetheless it's it's uh it's it's
interesting this is the whole new Batman
right it's DC taking Batman back to the
way he was back during the 60s and the
70s where he had some semblance of
high-tech gadgetry but Batman comics
were largely relying on Bruce Wayne's
intuition right his intelligence his
detective skills and some measure of
super Advanced gadgetry but in recent
years I would say Batman comics have
largely focused and shifted their focus
to like Bruce Wayne being able to
achieve his goals using like super
high-tech stuff and I'm excited to read
comics where it's just Batman and his
intellect I'm excited to read that it's
a throwback to the to the comic to the
Batman comics of yester year and I'm
looking forward to it a lot so with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to Comic explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like I will'll catch you
all
later
[Music]
peace
d
[Music]
oh
sh